ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GIPSON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. CURRY ARAMBULA OUR
QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRADE GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RATE. THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SARDO SMITH STONE
THING CALAVERAS THE APPROVED
VIA VOEPEL WALDRON BOARD WEBER
WICKS. WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN AMONG USERS. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. WE REJOICE
AND GIVE THANKS TO GOD. WHO HAS
RAISED UP HEROIC PEOPLE AND
EVERY AGE. THE LORD S TRUE TO
HIS NAME AND FAITHFUL TO HIS
PROMISES. THE LORD REWARDS THE
JUST. AND IT'S COMPASSIONATE TO
THE BROKEN HEARTED. MAY WE BE
INSPIRED BY THOSE WHO HAVE GONE
BEFORE US AND ARE REMEMBERED
FOR THEIR NOBLE DEEDS. AND
THEIR LIVES OF DEDICATION TO
ESTABLISH THIS NATION. ANYONE
ELSE THAT BRINGS JUSTICE TO ALL
I MEAN. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AS SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER FRIEDMAN READY
BEGIN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE BAR. AVERAGE PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING MEMBERS. PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING. ON AUGUST TWENTY SIX
A SUICIDE BOMBER DETONATED AT
THE KABUL AIRPORT. IN
AFGHANISTAN. TRAGICALLY
THIRTEEN MEMBERS OF THE US
ARMED FORCES LOST THEIR LIVES
IN THIS HORRIFIC ATTACK. MANY
CALIFORNIANS ANSWER THE CALL
THE MILITARY SERVICE. AND SADLY
FOUR OF THEM DIED WHILE SERVING
OUR NATION. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RAMOS MAYES
KILEY EDUARDO GARCIA AND
CERVANTES. THE ASSEMBLY AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE HONOR THIS
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE AND
RECOGNIZE THE VALOR OF THOSE
TAKEN OF US TAKEN FROM US FAR
TOO SOON. ALL FOR SURE IN THE
MARINE CORPS. THEY ARE SERGEANT
NICOLE G. OF ROSEVILLE.
CORPORAL HUNTER LOPEZ OF INDIO.
LANCE CORPORAL DYLAN MAROA OF
RANCHO CUCAMONGA LANCE CORPORAL
KAREEM THE C<c.cyan>G OF NORTEL. I</c>
ASK THE MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE
AND THOSE PRESENT THROUGHOUT
THE CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
TO PLEASE STAND AS WE OBSERVE A
MOMENT OF SILENCE AS PART OF
OUR GERMAN IN MEMORY FOR THESE
FALLEN HEROES.
THANK YOU
MEMBERS. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
MONDAY JUNE TWENTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY MET AT
ONE PM THE HONORABLE
CHRISTOPHER IN MORE ACTING
SPEAKER RECENTLY PRESIDING
CHIEF CLERK SHE PART OF THE
BEST READING COURAGEOUS MOVES
AND MISTER FLORA SECONDS. THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
AND REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
IT'S MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. WE ARE
AT PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THIS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION. MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ROBERT
RIVAS GIPSON HOLDEN AND COOLEY
TO SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
THE SENATE FOR FURTHER ACTION
AB SIX SIX THREE CHEN AB ONE
THREE FOUR NINE MATHIS AND AB
FOUR EIGHT TO WARD. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MR LEVINE FOR WHAT
PURPOSE ARE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MOVE TO REQUIRE
MEMBERS TO SUBMIT EVIDENCE OF
RECEIVING AT LEAST ONE DOSE OF
THE COVE IT NINETEEN
VACCINATION OR EVIDENCE OF A
DISABILITY. VACCINATION TO
CAPITAL HEALTH SERVICES BY FIVE
PM ON SEPTEMBER FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CAPITAL HEALTH
SERVICES WILL SUBMIT A LIST OF
MEMBERS WHO DO NOT SUBMIT SUCH
EVIDENCE TO THE ASSEMBLY RULES
COMMITTEE FOR CERTIFICATION.
THE ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE
WILL PROVIDE THE MEMBERSHIP OF
THE ASSEMBLY A LIST OF MEMBERS
WHO DO NOT SUBMIT SUCH
EVIDENCE. AND MEMBERS WHO DO
NOT PRESENT SUCH EVIDENCE SHALL
BE SUBJECT TO A MOTION AFTER
SEPTEMBER FIRST TO BE SUSPENDED
FROM EXERCISING THE POWERS OF
THE OFFICE AND FORFEIT. ALL
SALARY AND BENEFITS DERIVED
FROM THE OFFICE PURSUANT TO
ARTICLE FOUR SECTION FIVE UNTIL
THEY HAVE SUBMITTED SUCH
EVIDENCE. I NEED A SECOND
ANYBODY. THIS MOTION NEEDS A
SECOND.
THANK YOU. VETERANS
EARLIER YOUR RECOGNIZE- I MOVED
TO RE FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVIN'S MOTION TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE CAN BE PROPERLY ADDRESSED
THAT REQUIRES A SECOND SECOND
ABOUT MR CHILD MEMBERS THIS IS
A PROCEDURAL VOTE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. RAMOS IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE THIS. MR LEVINE
IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. MS
REYES AND MISS WALDRON ARE
ASKING FOR AND I. VOTE AND MR
LEVINE IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE
THIS IS PROCEDURAL MEMBERS.
THIS IS PROCEDURAL MS REYES AND
MISS WALDRON ARE ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MR LEVINE IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. WELL
CLOSER ALL EYES FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS. THREE THAT MOTION
CARRIES. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CLUB. AS A POINT
OF ORDER HE- YEAH.
SECOND
READING COVERAGE. SENATE BILL
THREE FORTY THREE AND SYMBOL
THIRTY FIVE. ALL BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO START. WITH SENATE
BILLS. WE ARE GOING TO START ON
SENATE THIRD.
MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING AND FILE ORDER ON SENATE
THIRD IF YOU'RE FLOOR JOCKEY
PLEASE BE READY WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE EXPEDITIOUSLY. WE'RE
STARTING AT. SEVEN THIRTY. OKAY.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY SIX. FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SIX IS SB THREE ELEVEN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS COURT
AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS. SENATE
BILL THREE ELEVEN WITH THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD DOCTOR WOULD ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MET MEN AND
MEMBERS THESE AMENDMENTS
INCORPORATE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND DO THREE
THINGS NUMBER ONE THEY DELETE
THE PROHIBITION ON HEALTH
FACILITIES FROM INTERFERING OR
PROHIBITING A PATIENT FROM
USING MEDICAL CARE MET MEDICAL
CANNABIS WITHIN THE FACILITY.
AND INSTEAD REQUIRE A HEALTH
CARE FACILITY TO PERMIT THE PER
PATIENT USE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS
SECOND REQUIRES A HEALTH
FACILITY TO REASONABLY RESTRICT
THE MANNER IN WHICH A PATIENT'S
STORES AND USES USES MET
MEDICAL CANNABIS INCLUDING
REQUIRING THAT THE CANNABIS BE
STORED IN A LOCKED CONTAINER.
AND FINALLY REQUIRE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES PERMITTING PATIENT
USE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS TO
COMPLY WITH SPECIFIC SPECIFIED
DRUG MEDICATION REQUIREMENTS
SUBJECT TO THE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS ARE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND AT THE
BILL TO GO OUT TO BRING IT BACK
ON FILE. THANK YOU DR WOOD
MISTER FLORA. WE WITHHOLD NOW
AS AN ASTEROID CALLED ON THESE
AND- MR FOR IS WITH. MEMBERS WE
WILL A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. MAJORITY
PRESIDENT VOTING IS THE
THRESHOLD ON THE IMMENSE
IMMENSE. CLARK WELL. CLITORAL I
SWITCHED TO KNOWS ONE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED BILLS
OUT TO PRINT AND BACKGROUND
FILE PASSERINE TEN A FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN THROUGH EIGHTY.
SAYS FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE SB
THREE FIFTEEN CORPORATE SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTEEN BY
SIDDARAMAIAH AND AFTER LEARNING
TO READ REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON
DEATH DEEDS MISTER CHOW. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB THREE FIFTEEN A BILL THAT
WILL AUTHORIZED TO CONTINUE USE
AND STUDY OF REVOCABLE TRANSFER
ON DEATH DEEDS AND EMERGING
ESTATE PLANNING TOOL THAT
ALLOWS CALIFORNIANS TO PASS ON
REAL PROPERTY TO THEIR HEIRS.
FOR MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOMEOWNERS REAL PROPERTY IS THE
ONLY ASSET THEY CAN PASS ON TO
THEIR HEIRS YET HISTORICAL LATE
THE ESTABLISHMENT THIS FOR THEM
TO DO SO OFTEN REQUIRE COST
PROHIBITIVE PROBATE OR ESTATE
PLANNING ATTORNEY CONSULTATION.
IN RESPONSE THE REVOCABLE
TRANSFORM DEBT ON DEATH THE O.
R. T. O. D. D. WAS CREATED BY
THIS LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHAT AB ONE THIRTY NINE
TO ALLOW OWNERS OF REAL
PROPERTY TO TRANSFER THE
PROPERTY UPON DEATH. OUTSIDE OF
THE NORMAL PROBATE PROCEDURE
THIS PILOT PROGRAM HAS A
CURRENT SUNSET DATE OF JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SB THREE
FIFTEEN AND NEXT A TEN YEAR
SUNSET EXTENSION TO THE ARTICLE
R. T. O. DD PILOT PROGRAM AND
ADOPTS THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDED. RECOMMENDATION TO
STRENGTHEN TRANSFORMAR AND
BENEFICIARY PROTECTIONS AND
RESTRUCTURE THE RULES THAT
GOVERN A BENEFICIARY'S
LIABILITY FOR THE DECEASED
TRANSFORMERS AND SECURE DEBTS
FURTHER SB THREE FIFTEEN WILL
GIVE THE C. L. R. C. ADDITIONAL
TIME TO STUDY THE EFFICACY OF
OUR T. O. DEE DEE'S. EVALUATE
THESE REFORMS AND ALSO MAKE
ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THEIR CONTINUATION OR
TERMINATION SB THREE FIFTEEN
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WITH NO NO VOTES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
CHELSEA NOTICED OR DEBATE.
LOCAL LOCAL ROLE. THE SENATE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
HIGHS FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHTY TWO SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR WITH THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US
THIS RIVAS ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR
I'D LIKE TO A MAN SB SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR TO SPECIFY THAT THE
CODE SECTION PROPOSED BY THIS
BILL WOULD ONLY APPLY UNTIL
SUCH TIME THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS REVIEWED ITS CONTRACT WITH
THE NONPROFIT IN LIGHT OF A
STATE OF EMERGENCY FURTHER THE
AMENDMENTS SPECIFY THAT THIS
SECTION WOULD NOT APPLY TO
NONPROFIT GRANTS RENDERED.
ENTIRELY VOID BY THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
RIVAS. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE- SAY NAY THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED. BILLS OUT
TO PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE.
FILE ITEMS. FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE AND EIGHTY FOUR PASS AND
RETAIN THAT BRINGS US FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE SB THREE SIX THREE
CORPORATE SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY THREE BY CENTER LEYVA AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE INTO
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. MS GONZALEZ
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY
THREE WILL ENSURE THAT THE
AMERICAN LEGION AND AMERICAN
LEGION AUXILIARY WHICH RUN BOYS
STATE AND GIRLS STATE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE SIMILAR ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY TO STUDENTS. AS
WELL AS NOT DISCRIMINATE BASED
ON GENDER SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL REQUIRES THAT BOTH BOYS
STATE AND GIRLS STATE PROGRAMS
OFFER. SIMILAR CURRICULUM IN
ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
AND FACILITIES AN EQUAL NUMBER
OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARTICIPATION REGARDLESS OF
GENDER AND EQUAL LIMITATIONS ON
THE NUMBER OF NOMINATIONS PER
SCHOOL MANY OF US HAVE SEEN
VOICE STATE UP HERE AT THOUSAND
BOYS- IN THE CAPITAL LEARNING
ABOUT GOVERNMENT. AND DIDN'T
REALIZE THAT THE GIRLS IMPACTOR
SENT SOMEWHERE ELSE MY DAUGHTER
DID THAT WHILE I WAS HERE SHE
SIGNED UP FOR US IN APPLIED TO
BE A GIRL STATE THINKING SHE'D
GET TO COME TO THE CAPITOL AND
I'M- THIS DISPARITY HAS GONE ON
TOO LONG WE WANT WOMEN TO HAVE
THE SAME ACCESS. TO THE CAPITAL
AS THE BOYS CURRENTLY DEAL WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MS AGUIAR-CURRY ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WOULD JUST WANT TO
CONCUR WITH MY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ REGARDING SB THREE
SIXTY THREE. I HAVE TWIN A
NIECE AND NEPHEW BOTH WERE.
HONORED TO GO TO THE BURKE
GIRLS STATE AND BOYS STATE. AND
THE DISCREPANCIES ARE
INCREDIBLE. THE BOYS HAD A LOT
MORE OPPORTUNITY THE GIRLS-
MEETINGS WERE ONLY HALF DAY. SO
I JUST CAN'T BEGIN THE TO TWO
THANKING US SENATOR LABOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- IT
SHOULD BE EQUAL FOR ALL. THANK
YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY I SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARCLUB THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS AT ABOUT. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS FOR THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS EIGHTY SIX OR
EIGHTY EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE SB FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENDMENTS. SENATE BILL FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR WITH THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO.
IS RUBIO ON THE IMMENSE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THE
AMENDMENTS TO SB FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR AT THE DESK ARE TRAPPED
DURING A MAN'S AND TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
ISRAEL WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED. BILL SUCH PRINTER%
BACK ON FILE. ASCERTAIN ABOUT A
NINETY. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETY ONE SB FIVE SIXTY FOUR
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
COURT AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY FOUR
WITH A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW. PRESSURE LOW ON THE
MINUTES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SPEAKING COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
DAGLISH LOW. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY YES SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED. BILLS OUT TO PRINT
IMPACT ON FILE. PASTORATE JANA
FILE ITEM NINETY TWO FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE SB THREE SEVENTEEN
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
OPERATE WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTEEN WITH A
MEMBERS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO MR SANTIAGO ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU ARE
TYPICALLY OFTEN I VOTE. THANK
YOU MR SANTIAGO SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION. WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED. BILLS
AT THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE
PASSED RETAIN ABOUT A NINETY
FOUR. FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE SB
THREE TO SIX FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENITIES. SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY SIX WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD DOCTOR
WOULD ON THE MINUTES MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THESE ARE NON
SUBSTANTIVE CHAPTER NOT
AMENDMENTS RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE A- THANK YOU DOCTOR
WHAT. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE A THE MEMBERS ARE DR.
BILLS OUT THE PRINTER BACK ON
FILE PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
NINETY SIX THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN SB FIVE HUNDRED
CORPORATE. SENATE BILL FIVE
HUNDRED BY CINNAMON IN EQUITY
TO VEHICLES MR BERMAN. THANK
YOU MR CALL YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES SB FIVE HUNDRED
WILL REQUIRE ALL NEW LIGHT DUTY
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES UNDER A
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED ONE
POUNDS. TO BE ZERO EMISSION BY
MODEL YEAR TWENTY THIRTY ONE
THIS MASURE HELPS OUR STATE
ACHIEVE OUR AMBITIOUS YET
NECESSARY CLEANER GOALS
ESPECIALLY AS WE KNOW VEHICLE
EXHAUST TO BE SOME OF THE MOST
TOXIC POLLUTANTS. THE
CONVENIENCE OF SELF DRIVING
VEHICLES COULD DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND THEREFORE EMISSIONS TO
DELIVER ON THEIR PROMISE OF A
MORE EFFICIENT FUTURE
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE COMPANIES
SHOULD ADOPT A ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY. WHILE OUR COMMON
FUTURE DOES NOT REST ON ANYONE
POLICY REQUIRING AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES TO BE ZERO EMISSION IS
A CRITICAL FIRST STEP TO ENSURE
THIS DEVELOPING MARKET HELPS US
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE AND CLEAN
AIR TARGETS. SB FIVE HUNDRED IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
INDUSTRY GROUPS WORKING CLOSELY
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AMENDMENTS WERE MADE THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. THE
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM THE
CALCHAMBER THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION SELF DRIVING
COALITION AND SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
THIS BERMAN SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL. OUT OF ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT ABOUT. THE CLICK WELL
THOSE ARE ALL TIED UP IS FORTY
SIX NO SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM NINETY EIGHT THIS IS FILE
ITEM NINETY NINE SB FIVE FIVE
SIX. CORKERY SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY SIX BY SEVERAL DODD AND
OTHERS AND ACALANES
COMMUNICATIONS DR CORK FROM THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK DR PARK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
SB FIVE FIVE SIX WOULD BRING
CALIFORNIA CONFORMANCE WITH
EXISTING FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
SEEKING TO ACCELERATE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF WIRELESS
BROADBAND NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- THIS BILL REQUIRES
LOCALITIES TO GIVE ACCESS TO
THEIR STREET LIGHT AND TRAFFIC
SIGNAL POLES. IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE ORDER- FROM THE-
FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION. THE
BILL FOCUSES ON ENSURING THAT
ACCESS TO THESE POLLS IS
PROVIDED AT A NON
DISCRIMINATORY COST BASE RATE.
A SENATOR DODD AND AMENDMENTS
TO PRESERVE EXISTING AGREEMENTS
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY FOR
WIRELESS SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ENTER INTO
AGREEMENTS SPECIFIC TO LOCAL
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND BENEFITS HE
ALSO ADDED LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
EQUITABLE ACCESS. OR CRYING
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO MONITOR
THEIR PROGRESS TOWARD REACHING
CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSAL
BROADBAND GOALS VERY PROVIDING
WIRELESS BROADBAND COVERAGE BY
CENSUS TRACT ANNUALLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
CRITICALLY NEEDED LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR
FOR. SAYING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP. I
FIFTY ONE KNOWS EIGHT. THE
MEASURE PASSES.
EVERYONE TO
PASS A RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
HUNDRED THROUGH. ONE OH TWO.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE OF THREE
SB. SEVEN FOURTEEN. COOKERY
SENATE BILL SEVEN FOURTEEN BY
CENTER CABALLERO AND OTHERS AND
THAT RELATING TO ELECTIONS.
MISS KOREA. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR BECAUSE I GET ALL
AND A PROUD CO AUTHOR I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB SEVEN ONE
FOUR WHICH WOULD ALLOW ASPIRING
CITIZENS SUCH AS DREAMERS TO BE
APPOINTED AND ELECTED TO THE
COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE WITHIN
OUR DEMOCRATIC PARTY SB SEVEN
ONE FOR HELP CALIFORNIANS LEAD
THE WAY IN CREATING A MORE
INCLUSIVE DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM AND
REMOVE THE SYSTEMIC BARRIER
THAT KEEPS IMMIGRANT LEADERS
FROM A SEAT AT THE TABLE.
EXISTING LAW PROVIDES THAT A
PERSON MUST BE REGISTERED WITH
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN ORDER
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR AN
APPOINTMENT OR ELECTION TO A
COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE A
PERSON DOES THIS BY REGISTERING
TO VOTE AND CHOOSING A PARTY
AFFILIATION THIS MEANS THIS
MEANS STREAMERS WHO CANNOT
REGISTER TO VOTE CANNOT RUN FOR
CENTRAL COMMITTEE ELECTIONS IT
IS TIME THAT THE VOICES
EXPERIENCE AND TALENT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE RECOGNIZED AND
TRULY INTEGRATED AND ARE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THIS BILL IS A
LATINO CAUCUS PRIORITY AND
ENDORSED BY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CARRILLO.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL THE-
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
EIGHT. KNOWS NINE THAT MEASURE
PASSES ASCERTAIN ON FILE ITEMS
ONE OF FOUR ONE FIVE. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO. I AM
REFERRING ADAM SEVENTY ONE AJ
ARE TEN. TO THE MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
BACK IN FILE ORDER FILE ITEM
ONE OF SIX IS S. B. H. TWENTY
THREE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORKERY WITH
AMENDMENTS. SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY THREE WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD. DOCTOR
WOULD ON THE MENACE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS OF THE
FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS
INCORPORATE RECENTLY CHAPTER
LAW THE CONFLICTS WITH LANGUAGE
IN THIS BILL THE AMENDMENTS
ALSO INCLUDE DOUBLE JOINTING
LANGUAGE FOR AB FOUR SEVENTY
THREE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AB
SIX THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TO ADOPT THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YEAH SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS OUT TO
PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM ONE OF SEVEN PASS
RETAIN ON FILE I DON'T WANT TO
WAIT. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE OR
NINE SB THREE EIGHTY SIX FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. THIS
IS MISTER DALY CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY SIX
WITH A MINUTES BY SOME REMEMBER
DALY. MR DAILY ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
REQUESTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER DALY
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE DR. BILLS
OUT TO PRINT. IN BACK ON FILE
FILE ITEM ONE TEN THROUGH ONE.
WELL PASS A RETAIN THIS BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN SB.
ONE KERKORIAN'S SENATE BILL ONE
BY CENTER ATKINS AND OTHERS
IMMACULATE IN THE COASTAL
RESOURCES. MISS PATRIARCHS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB ONE WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH NEW PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION AND PUBLIC
AGENCY COORDINATION
REQUIREMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACTS OF SEA LEVEL RISE. OUR
TREASURE CALIFORNIA COAST IS
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY MILES
OF BREATHTAKING BEAUTY HOME TO
NEARLY 70% OF CALIFORNIANS AND
A CRITICAL ENGINE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY BUT ALL OF
THIS IS UNDER THREAT FROM
SEALEVEL RISE ALL OF THIS OVER
THE COURSE OF THIS CENTURY C.
LEVELS ARE EXPECTED TO RISE BY
SEVEN FEET THIS PUTS. MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS AND BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AT RISK
WE MUST ACT NOW TO SAFEGUARD
OUR COASTAL COMMUNITIES AND SB
ONE IS THE FIRST COMPREHENSIVE
SEA LEVEL RISE PROGRAM IN OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT TO ASSESS AND
MITIGATE SILVA RISE AND TO
ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
COMMUNITIES IN RESPONDING TO
THIS MOUNTING CRISIS. AMONG
OTHER PROVISIONS SB ONE
REQUIRES THE COASTAL COMMISSION
TO ADOPT AN UPDATE STANDARDS
FOR USE AND LOCAL AND REGIONAL
COASTAL PLANNING IN ORDER TO
MORE EFFECTIVELY IDENTIFY
ASSESS AND MITIGATE SEA LEVEL
RISE IT ESTABLISHES NEW FUNDING
FOR STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO PLAN FOR AND MITIGATE SEA
LEVEL RISE. AND EXPANDS OUR
EXISTING CAL EPA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GRANT PROGRAM FOR THOSE
THAT DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
MOSTINDEED FOR OUR ENTIRE STATE I-
JUST ASK ACT NOW TO CONFRONT
THIS SLOW MOVING TSUNAMIARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. ONE- THIS BILL WAS
HEARD IN OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE AND ADDRESSES THE
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF SEA LEVEL
RISE. A RECENT SCIENTIFIC STUDY
BY USGS RESEARCHERS PREDICTED
THAT UNDER POSSIBLE SCENARIOS
OF SEA LEVEL RISE AND ABSENT
ACTIONS TO MITIGATE SUCH
IMPACTS UP TO TWO THIRDS OF
SOUTHERNCALIFORNIA BEACHES MAY
BECOME COMPLETELY ERODED BY THE
YEAR TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. THE L.
A. O. RELEASED A REPORT A FEW
YEARS AGO ENTITLED PREPARING
FOR RISING SEAS HOW THE STATE
CAN HELP SUPPORT LOCAL COASTAL
ADAPTATION EFFORTS. THE REPORT
STATED THAT COASTAL ADAPTATION
ACTIVITIES CAN HELP LESSEN SEA
LEVEL RISE IMPACTS AND MADE
SEVERAL POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
TO PLAN AND REDUCE SEA LEVEL
IMPACTS. SB ONE IMPLEMENTS MANY
OF THE L. A. O.'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WILL
PROVIDE THE FUNDING TO LESSEN
C. LEVEL RISE IMPACTS AND
THAT'S WHY I URGE MEMBERS TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY THIS IS
ONE A BIG ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA-
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB ONE. THANK YOU
MS REVERSE. SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM IS PETRIE-NORRIS
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH I
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
THINK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES FOR THOSE COMMENTS
AND THANK YOU ALSO ADD TO THE
BILL'S AUTHOR SENATOR ATKINS
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE- AND WITH THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICT THREE KNOWS ELEVEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
ONE FOURTEEN THROUGH ONE
SIXTEEN. PASS AND RETAIN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN. S.
B.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN SB SIXTY EIGHT
CORRECT SENATE BILL 68% OF
BECKER AND OTHERS ARE NOT GOING
TO ELECTRICITY MS CARILLO YOUR
MAIL. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
BACKGROUND A PROTOCOL
AUTHORIZED TO PRESENT SB SIXTY
EIGHT INCREASING THE USE OF
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND BUILDINGS
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PATHWAY TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS AND REDUCE AIR POLLUTION.
THE TECHNOLOGY TO DO THIS EXIST
TODAY BUT THEIR MERIT MAJOR
BARRIERS OF ITS ADOPTION THIS
BILL REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO PUBLISH
GUIDANCE ON OVERCOMING BARRIERS
TO BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION AND
CONSIDER PROJECT ADVANCING
TECHNOLOGY THAT LOWERS THE COST
OF BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION.
BETTER IFORMATION AND BETTER
TECHNOLOGY WILL MAKE IT EASIER
FOR OWNERS TO ELECTRIFY THE
ENERGY USE IN THEIR BUILDINGS
AND PROVIDE CHARGERS FOR THEIR
VEHICLES I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
PERU. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON THE ADAM CLICK
LIBERAL. IT IS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AND ABOUT. BURKE
WELL. CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED OUT
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM OF ONE
EIGHTEEN. THROUGH ONE TWENTY
ASCERTAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY ONE S. B. NINETY SEVEN.
CORKERY SENATE BILL NINETY
SEVEN BY CENTER OFTEN ACCORDING
TO PEOPLE HEALTH MR BONTA S.
YOU MAY OPEN MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL NINETY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR RICHARD ROTH WHICH WILL
HELP BRIDGE THE GAP THAT EXISTS
IN THE INFORMATION PROVIDED TO
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS ON EARLY
TYPE ONE DIABETES OR T. WENDY
DETENTION AND DIAGNOSES T. ONE
D. IS AN AUTOIMMUNE SYSTEM
DISEASE THAT ATTACKS THE
PANCREAS PREVENTING IT FROM
MAKING INSULIN WITH THE LACK OF
INSULIN A RISE IN BLOOD GLUCOSE
CAN QUICKLY LEAD TO SERIOUS
HEALTH PROBLEMS INCLUDING DOT.
T. WENDY CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO DETECT PARTICULARLY IN
CHILDREN AND WHILE MANY
ADVANCES HAVE BEEN MADE IN THE
TREATMENT OF THIS LIFE ALTERING
DISEASE EARLY DETENTION AND
DIAGNOSIS CAN HELP DRASTICALLY
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
CHAU OF A CHILD WITH T. ONE D.
SB NINETY SEVEN EMPOWERS
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS TO BETTER
BE ADVOCATES FOR STUDENTS
HEALTH BY REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP T. WENDY
INFORMATIONAL MATERIAL ON EARLY
WARNING SIGNS AND RISK FACTORS
THIS BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO SHARE THESE
MATERIALS WITH PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS OF STUDENTS UPON
ENROLLMENT IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. KNOWLEDGE IS POWER IN
THE EARLY DETENTION AS WELL AS
TREATMENT AND MANAGEMENT OF T.
ONE D. PARENTS AND STUDENTS
MUST BE ARMED WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE SPOT THIS DISEASE IT
HAS RECEIVED SUPPORT FROM THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. SAY YOU MISTER FUND HAS
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOUR
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER JUST REAL QUICK MEMBERS
ON A PERSONAL NOTE ONE OF OUR
KIDS IS TYPE ONE DIABETIC.
SHE'S IN NINTH GRADE SHE'S.
VERY HEALTHY BUT IT IS A- ROUND
THE CLOCK CONSTANT MANAGEMENT
ISSUE. AND I CAN ASSURE YOU.
THAT A LOT OF THE COACHES AND
THE TEACHERS AND THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM DO NOT
UNDERSTAND. TYPE ONE DIABETICS
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TYPE ONE AND
TYPE TWO. AND THIS BILL IS A
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT THING
THAT I GUARANTEE WILL SAVE KIDS
LIVES AND I THINK AUTHORED FOR
KERRY. THANK YOU MISS
CUNNINGHAM. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. LOCAL CONTROL MEMBERS. IT
IS OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT ABOUT. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY TWO
THROUGH ONE TWENTY FOUR PASS
AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY FIVE SB TWO TO ONE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORKERY WITH IMMENSE SENATE
BILL TWO TWENTY ONE WITH THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON. MISS WALDRON. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR WIENER I
SUBMIT AMENDMENTS FOR S. B. TWO
TWO ONE TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL
UNTIL JULY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT
TO PRINTER BACK ON FILE. FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX THROUGH.
ONE TWENTY NINE. PASSERINE TEN.
SAYS FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY. SB
TWO SIX SIX. CORPORATE SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTY SIX MONTHS IN A
NEWMAN AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
IN STATE PARKS DR CHEN KAMALA
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT SB TWO SIX SIX ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR NEWMAN
REQUIRES A CALVET APARTMENT OF
PUBLIC WORKS AND PARKS AND
RECREATION CORPORATE THREE
PROPERTIES ADJACENT TO CHINO
HILLS STATE PARK INTO THE PARK
THE STATE PARTS DEPARTMENT AND
LOCAL CONSERVATION GROUPS
IDENTIFIED THESE LANDS FOR
ACQUISITION CHANNEL STATE PARKS
AND SPANS THREE COUNTIES ORANGE
COUNTY RIVERSIDE IN SANDERS
COUNTY AND TOUCHES A FOURTH LOS
ANGELES. THE JUNGLE STATE PARK
HAS MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ANNUAL VISITORS AND
LIES WITHIN LOS ANGELES BASIN
WHICH HAS A POPULATION OF MORE
THAN SEVEN MILLION PEOPLE
WITHIN A TWENTY FIVE MILE
RADIUS THESE PROPERTIES WILL
ADD ABOUT ONE THOUSAND FIVE OR
THIRTY ACRES OF THE PARK
EMBEDDED IN THESE PARTICLES ARE
GROSS OF THE MOMENT WOODLAND
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S RARE AND
IMPERILED NATURAL COMMUNITIES
AND HABITAT FOR DEER AND
MOUNTAIN LIONS AND
CORPORATIZATION LANDS IN CHINO
HILLS STATE PARK HELP
CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF
PRESERVING THIRTY PERCENT. OF
THE STATE'S LAND AND COASTAL
WATERS BY. TWENTY THIRTY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU DOCTOR CHEN. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE WELL
CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY ONE S. B. TWO SIX SEVEN.
OPERATE SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
IMMACULATE INTO TAXATION TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY MR WARD EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER SB TWO SIXTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
PROVIDE STATUTORY CLARIFICATION
FOR ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
CERTAINTY TO SOLAR INVESTMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA THE BILL
CLARIFIES THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN THE CURRENT PROPERTY
TAX EXCLUSION AND THE SOLAR
FINANCING STRUCTURE CALLED A
PARTNERSHIP FLIP PARTNER
SUPPORT STRUCTURES ARE USED TO
FINANCE THEM MOST SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA AND CAME
ABOUT AS A WAY TO MAXIMIZE THE
USE OF FEDERAL INVESTMENT TAX
CREDITS. TOGETHER THESE KEY TAX
MEASURES WERE TO DRIVE DOWN
COSTS AND HAVE MADE SOLAR ONE
OF THE CHEAPEST ENERGY SOURCES
AVAILABLE SB TWO SIX SEVEN
HELPS ENSURE CALIFORNIA CAN
REMAIN A LEADER IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SOLAR AND
COMBATING CLIMATE CHANGE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
EITHER. THANK YOU MISS WARD. C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. BURKE WILL OVER THE ROLE
MEMBERS VOTE. ROSARIO ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY NINE KNOWS ONE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE PROGRAM
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TO PASS A
RETAIN FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
THREE SB TWO SEVENTY CORPORATE
CYNICAL TO SEVENTY BY SENATOR
ALSO ENACTED IN THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT. MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB TWO
SEVENTY WILSHIRE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVE
ACCURATE AND TIMELY BARGAINING
UNIT INFORMATION. WITH THE
ALREADY TELL TO BY LAW SO THEY
MAY FULFILL THEIR LEGAL
REPRESENTATIONAL DUTIES TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE BARGAINING
UNIT AS A WHOLE. THIS MEASURE
CREATES NO NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ASSEMBLY
INCENTIVIZES COMPLIANCE WITH
EXISTING LAW PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY TO EMPLOYERS. TO A
MEET THEIR CURRENT LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS. SB TWO SEVENTY
GIVE THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT BOARD. THE FULL AND
COMPLETE AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE
WHAT SOLUTIONS WILL WORK TO
BOTH ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW THE COMPANY THE OBLIGATIONS
THAT PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. ARE
FACING RIGHT NOW. THIS BILL
PASSES IN THE LAST YEAR WITH
FIFTY FIVE VOTES BUT DIED AT
MIDNIGHT BEFORE RECEIVING
CURRENT VOTE. FOR THESE REASONS
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING SB TWO SEVENTY BEFORE YOU
RESPECTFULLY URGE ALIVE A.
THANK YOU MISS COOPER. SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM SEVERAL OF THE ROLE.
SEVERAL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE
OF. CLARK WELL. CLOSE THE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY FOUR NO
NOS ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR. WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY FIVE S. B. TWO
NINETY SIX. CORPORATION SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY SIX BY CENTER
LEóN AND ACTED IN THE CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS MISTER
JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ARE CHARGED WITH
ENFORCING STATE AND LOCAL
HOUSING LAWS AND VARIOUS PATHS
MOLD LEAD AND OTHER REGULATIONS
CONCERNING HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
AND CONDITIONS THIS WORK IS
CRITICAL TO IMPROVING HOUSING
CONDITIONS HEALTH AND SAFETY.
AND QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
WORK CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ARE EXPOSED TO A RANGE OF
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS
ENVIRONMENT. CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS OFTEN THREATENED
HARASSED OR EVEN ASSAULTED AND
TRAGICALLY THERE HAVE BEEN. A
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS HAVE
BEEN MURDERED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY. THE CURRENT COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS ALSO IT
INCREASE HEALTH THREATS TO CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO
CONTINUE TO WORK DESPITE COULD
BE ADDITIONAL HAS A TODAY
HEALTH. WHILE MANY CITIES HAVE
DEVELOP SAFETY STANDARDS TO
HELP PROTECT PEACE OFFICERS.
MANAGERS DISTRICT DITIONS LAX
SAFETY STANDARDS APPLICABLE TO
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS SB
TWO NINETY SIX WHAT DIRECT EACH
LOCAL JURISDICTION EMPLOYERS
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
DEVELOP AN APPROPRIATE SAFETY
STANDARDS BASED ON THE NATURE.
OF THEIR WORK AND ISSUES THEY
FACE. CRATING SAFETIES IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO PROTECT CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THAT
RESTORE SAFETY HEALTH AND LIFE
PROTECT IN OUR COMMUNITY. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AS
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. RESERVE ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF IT.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASSER
CANNOT FILE OUT OF ONE THIRTY
SIX AND ONE THIRTY SEVEN. THIS
IS FILE AT ONE THIRTY EIGHT SB
THREE THIRTY CORPORATE. SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTY BY SENATOR
RAZA WHEN EQUITY TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MR SANTIAGO I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB THREE
THIRTY WOULD BE A COMMON SENSE
SOLUTION TO TACKLING THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROBLEM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT WOULD
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM FOR THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TO USE IT'S UNDER UTILIZED
SPACE. HI INTERNET AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR BOTH THE STUDENTS
AND ITS EMPLOYEES. I SPOKE LAST
NIGHT OF. THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
C. NOTIFICATION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY TWO KNOWS TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE SB
THREE THREE TWO COVERAGE SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTY TWO BY CENTER
DODD AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING
TO CIVIL LIABILITY. DR WOULD
YOU MAIL BUT THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB THREE
THIRTY TWO ESTABLISHES A GROSS
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD PROTECT
PRESCRIBED FIRE BURN BOSSES
FROM FIRE SUPPRESSION COSTS
RESULTING FROM THE OCCURRENCE
OF A PRESCRIBED FIRE.
ENCOURAGING MORE USE OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE THAN CURRENTLY
OCCURS IN THE STATE IS THE GOAL
OF SB THREE THIRTY TWO.
PRESCRIBED FIRES TYPICALLY DONE
OR SUPERVISED BY A BURN BOSSES
ARE QUALIFIED TO PLAN ORGANIZE
AND EXECUTE WHAT ARE KNOWS AS
PRESCRIBED OR CONTROLLED BURNS.
PRESCRIBED BURN IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT AND MOST COST
EFFECTIVE TOOLS TO REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK. ONE OF THE
PRIMARY CONCERNS FOR PRIVATE
PRESCRIBED FIRE PRACTITIONERS
IS THAT THEY WILL BE BUILT AT
THE CAL FIRE OTHER AGENCIES
PROVIDE SUPPRESSION SUPPORT ON
A BURN. SB THREE THIRTY TWO BUT
SPECIFIED THAT TRAINED AND
CERTIFIED BURN BOSSES PERSONS
THEY SUPERVISE PROPERTY OWNERS
WHO HIRE BURN BOSSES IN NATIVE
AMERICAN CULTURAL BURNERS ARE
SHIELDED FROM FIRE SUPPRESSION
COSTS UNLESS THEY CONDUCT A
BIRD IN A GROSSLY NEGLIGENT
MANNER. A BURN BOSS WOULD STILL
BE LIABLE FOR SUPPRESSION COSTS
AT THE ACTED RECKLESSLY BUT THE
BURN BOSSES CONDUCTING WORK FOR
PUBLIC BENEFIT USING BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
INCONSISTENT WITH THE BURN
PAYMENT THEY WILL NOT BE LIABLE
FOR THESE RARE BUT COSTLY
SUPPRESSION EXPENSES. SB THREE
THIRTY TO AS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES THE
TIMBER STREET INDUSTRY PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURERS PYROGEN
SEASON MORE THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD
MISTER FOR. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK IT WAS A SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT AS A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR OF SB THREE THREE TWO
PRESCRIBED BURNS ARE A PROVEN
FOREST FIRE MITIGATION TACTIC
BUT THEY ARE SUBJECT TO
STRINGENT BARRIERS AT THE
MOMENT BY CHANGING THE STANDARD
OF NEGLIGENCE FOR BURN BOSSES
THIS BILL WILL HELP TO INCREASE
THE USE OF PRESCRIBED BURNS
SAFELY REMOVE FORCE FUEL.
REDUCE THE HARMFUL EMISSIONS
FROM DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES AND
RESTORE FOR SOUTH EVERY YEAR
OUR FORCE ARE FILLED WITH MORE
MORE FUELS AS HUNDRED OF
THOUSANDS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF ACRES OF DRY BRUSH AND DYING
TREES ARE LEFT UNTREATED. WE
MUST LOOK FOR WAYS TO PREVENT
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES AND
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT SB THREE THREE
TWO. ARJUN ABOUT. THANK YOU
MISS FONG MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO RISE AND
SUPPORT SB THREE THREE TWO
PRESCRIBED FIRE IS A- MUCH
NEEDED TOOL IN FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT AND THIS WILL HELP
INSURE THAT MORE PEOPLE CAN
UTILIZE THIS METHOD AS WE SEEK
TO. MAKE OUR FORESTS HEALTHIER
AND PREVENT CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS GALLAGHER I SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. DR WHEN
YOU MAKE CLOTHES WE WISH THANK
MY COLLEAGUES AND TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NUMBER.
COUPLE OF NARAL. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. TELL MEMBERS OTHERS AT A
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE OUT OF ONE
FORTY THREE ONE FORTY THREE
PASS AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY FOUR. SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY FIVE CORKERY.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY FIVE BY
CENTER CABALLERO AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE MEDICAL MYSTERY
THIS EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- I'M PLEASED TO.
PRESENT THIS BILL WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE- THE MEDICARE TO
REIMBURSE ALL OF A- SOME
PARTICIPATING- TO PRIMARY CARE.
FIGHTERS I INCLUDING THOSE WHO
OPERATE OUT OF A FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER OR A
RULE HEALTH CENTER OR FORTY
CONSULTING SERVICES- AS OF NOW
THE THIS IS A SERVICE IS ONLY
REIMBURSABLE FOR SPECIAL TO
THIS- FOR SOME. SOME SPECIALIST
PROVIDERS NOT PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS- AND SO THIS CHANGE
WOULD CERTAINLY. B. OF- YOU
KNOW- MUCH HELP TO OUR PATIENTS
AND RULE OR IN RURAL OR
UNDERSERVED AREAS- AND
CERTAINLY WOULD. GREATLY
INCREASED ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
FOR THESE- RESIDENTS AND THESE
AREAS THE USE OF AN ECON SALT
ALSO. HELPS WOULD WOULD WOULD
ALSO DETERMINE IF I A PHYSICAL
VISIT IS IN FACT NEEDED SAVING
THE PATIENT TIME AND MONEY-
THIS IS A SMALL CHANGE TO THAT
THE LAW WILL IT IT WILL ONLY.
IT IT WILL NOT ONLY TREAT FROM.
THE PRIMARY CARE SOME PROVIDERS
MORE FAIRLY BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WILL IMPROVE CARE
FOR THOSE- THESE PATIENTS ALL
ACROSS OUR STATE AND SO WITH
THAT RESPECT US WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK GOODNESS RIVAS.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLICK LIBERAL
MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE. WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
SIX. NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEMS ONE OF FORTY
FIVE THROUGH ONE FORTY SEVEN
PASS AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE
OUT OF ONE FORTY EIGHT. THIS IS
MISS FRIEDMAN FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY EIGHT S. B. THREE SEVEN
TWO. OPERATOR SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY TWO BY CENTER LEYVA AND
OTHER CYNICAL IN THE VEHICLES
MISTREATMENT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBER SO WE ALL HAVE
HEARD MANY TIMES ABOUT HOW THE
ONE DIRECTION IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE GONE THE WRONG DIRECTION
WHEN IT COMES TO REDUCING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IS A
HEAVY DUTY TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR BEING OUR TRUCKS AND
FREIGHT MOVEMENT- ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS WITH TRANSITIONING OUR
TRANSPORTATION FLEETS TO
PARTICULARLY HEAVY DUTY FLEETS
TO BEING ZERO EMISSION IS THAT
THE INCENTIVES THAT WE ALREADY
OFFER UNDER CURRENT LAW CAN BE
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR TRUCK
DRIVERS WERE LOOKING TO BUY A
NEW TRUCK. TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO
ACCESS THERE'S VERY LITTLE IN
TERMS OF JUST ONE SHOP STOP
SHOPPING FOR THEM TO UNDERSTAND
THE INCENTIVES THAT ARE ON THE
TABLE SB THREE SEVENTY TWO
ESTABLISHES THE MINIMUM AND
HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE FLEET PURCHASING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WHICH WILL
IN CONSULTATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WILL DESIGN NEW
FINANCING TOOLS TO HELP THESE
OPERATORS OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES ACQUIRED ZERO
EMISSION ALTERNATIVES THIS BILL
HAS EARNED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN. SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. LOCAL
OF NARAL. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. TO DECIDE ABOUT. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLE TYLER. HIGHS. SIXTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
ROLE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO MY
FAVOR. I AM REFERRING SB THREE
ELEVEN HUESO TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. BACK
IN FOLLOW ORDER WE'RE GOING TO
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY NINE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY SB THREE NINETY.
COOKERY SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY BY THE CENTRE LAYERED
AND OTHERS AND ACCORDING TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE MISS
WAKES YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB THREE
NINETIES A RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE STATE AUDITOR FOLLOWING THE
AUDIT OF THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT THAT
WILL REQUIRE THE EIGHTY TO
ESTABLISH AND ROUTINELY REVISE
A RECESSION PLAN THE RECESSION
PLAN WILL ENSURE THAT EASY CAN
RAPIDLY AND EFFICIENTLY RESPOND
TO AN INCREASE OF CLAIMS DUE TO
AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. THE PLAN
CONTAINS PROCEDURES PRACTICES
AND PROTOCOLS TO ACQUIT THE
EIGHTY TO HANDLE AN INCREASED
WORKLOAD THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY
BOTH BUSINESS AND LABOR ENJOYS
BIPRTISAN CO AUTHORS DOES
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SB THREE NINETY THANK
YOU. I THANK HIM AS WICKS C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CARCLUB LIBERAL MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
WERE DESIRABLE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. PASS RETAIN PARDON ME.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
OUT OF ONE FIFTY ONE THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE SB
THREE NINETY FOUR CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
FOUR BY IT SOONER HUESO
IMMACULATE INTO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS MR SANTIAGO
YOU MAY OPEN I THINK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BILL SIMPLY
CLARIFY THE TWO PEOPLE IN THE
SAME ADDRESS CAN OBTAIN THE
LIFELINE SUBSCRIPTION WHICH FOR
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE TELEPHONE
SERVICES FOR LOW INCOME. PEOPLE
AS LONG AS THEY'RE SEPARATE
ECONOMIC UNITS RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU FOR SANTIAGO
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLICK
LIBERAL. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. IS OUT OF. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF ART I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY TWO THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY THREE SB FOUR OH
THREE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR OH THREE BY SOONER
GONZALEZ AND OTHER FINANCE
RELATED TO DRINKING WATER. DR A
REGULAR EMAIL. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
FOUR OH THREE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ. THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE STATE WATER
AUTHORITIES WITH AN IMPORTANT
TOOL TO HELP CALIFORNIA FINALLY
REALIZE THE HUMAN RIGHTS TO
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER. CONSOLIDATION IS AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL IN IMPROVING
ACCESS TO SAFE WATER BECAUSE
LARGER CONSOLIDATED SYSTEMS ARE
GENERALLY MORE RELIABLE SAFE
AND EFFICIENT. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SENATE BILL FOUR OH
THREE. THANK YOU DOCTOR REGULAR
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THESE
ARE NOT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESERT
ABOUT. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ICE FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY FOUR
THROUGH. ONE FIFTY SEVEN PASS
RETAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY EIGHT SB FOUR EIGHTY
THREE. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CARPOOL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS. SENATE BILL FORTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN MISTER
BRIAN ON THE AMENDMENT. THE
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARRIVED HAVE SB
FORTY THREE THE FLOOR
AMENDMENTS FROM THE AUTHOR
REFLECT THE COMPROMISE BETWEEN
STAKEHOLDERS THAT REMOVES THANK
YOU OPPOSITION OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE ADOPTION OF THESE MEN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRIME WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS OUT TO
PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. ONE FIFTY NINE.
SB FOUR NINETY FOUR SEPARATE
SENATE BILL FOUR NINETY FOUR BY
CENTER DODD ENACTED INTO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. MEMBERS WERE ONE
OF PASS TEMPORARILY. WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY NINE AS BEFORE NINETY
FOUR. CLARK RT REDNESS
BARRICADE EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER SB FOUR NINETY
FOUR WOULD REQUIRE POST TO
CREATE OFFICER TRAINING ON
INTERVIEW TECHNIQUES WHICH ARE
MORE EFFECTIVE AT GETTING
INFORMATION WHILE AVOIDING
FALSE CONFESSIONS AND
STATEMENTS OVER THE PAST
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS POLICE HAVE
RELIED ON A CRIMINAL
INTERROGATION STRATEGY KNOWN AS
THE REID TECHNIQUE WHICH RELIES
HEAVILY ON ASSUMING GUILT AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL MANIPULATION
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED
ABOUT THE VALIDITY OF THE
TECHNIQUE WITH STUDIES SHOWING
THE ABILITY OF AN OFFICER TO
DETECTIVE SECTION AT AROUND
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT. SB FOUR
NINETY FOUR WOULD HELP TO
ENSURE OFFICERS ARE PROPERLY
TRAINED AND STOP UTILIZING
THESE COERCIVE TACTICS THEY CAN
RESULT IN FALSE STATEMENTS
FURTHER IT WOULD REQUIRE
TRAINING TO ENSURE EVERYDAY
INTERACTIONS WITH THE PUBLIC-
CIVIL THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
MULTIPLE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AS
WELL AS THE INNOCENCE PROJECT
AND MEMBERS I THINK AS WE TALK
FREQUENTLY ON THIS FOR ABOUT
WHAT IT IS WE CAN DO TO ENSURE
THAT THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM INCARCERATE THOSE WHO
ARE GUILTY. AND IS NOT
INCARCERATE THOSE THAT ARE
INNOCENT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THAT PUZZLE BY
ENSURING THAT ALL STATEMENTS
THAT END UP ADMITTED AT THE
TIME A TRIAL ARE ACCURATE AND
REFLECT THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS BACKING HIM.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. GLOBAL OF NARAL.
MEMBERS VOTE FOR THIS ARTICLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF.
CARDWELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I. SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY. SB FOUR NINETY
SIX CORKERY. SENATE BILL FOUR
NINETY SIX BY CENTER LAYERED
AND OTHERS ENACT LEADING TO
WATER. MYSTERY OF US YOU MAILED
ME. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
THIS LEGISLATION BY SIMILAR IT
IS A- IT'S A DISTRICT BILL AND
IT SEEKS TO THE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
TO EXCEED THE- STATE'S 70% COST
SHARE FUNDING CEILING FOR WATER
PROJECTS THAT MEET CERTAIN.
CRITERIA RELATING TO LOCAL
HYDROLOGIC CONDITIONS AND
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP THE POWELL
RIVER FLOOD RISK MANAGEMENT
PROJECT IN OUR DISTRICT MEETS
ALL OF THE CRITERIA. THIS BILL
COMES AT A TIME WHEN FLOOD
PROTECTION ALONG THE POWER THE
PAPAROA RIVER SYSTEM IS SOME OF
THE WORST IN OUR STATE. SINCE
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE FLOOD
CONTROL INFRASTRUCTURE THE
REGION HAS EXPERIENCED SIX
MAJOR FLOODS. UNFORTUNATELY
HOWEVER THE LOCAL- THE
COMMUNITY IS SEVERELY. THIS
DISADVANTAGED AND UNABLE TO
FULLY AFFORD THE NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES. THIS
LEGISLATION WAS SOLVED THIS
PROBLEM BY INCREASING THE
STATE'S KASHA THRESHOLD FOR THE
PAPAROA RIVER PROJECT THIS BILL
IS ENJOYED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS REAVIS MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINETY SIX
EASY TO FORGET- DURING DROUGHT
THAT WE HAVE. DEVASTATING
FLOODS IN THE STATE AS WELL.
AND SO THE MORE THAT WE CAN
HELP OUT WITH NEEDED FLOOD
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ESPECIALLY IN OUR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY MAY NOT
HAVE THE TAX BASE TO SUPPORT
THOSE PROJECTS I THINK THIS IS
A GOOD GOOD MEASURE SO I ASK
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS GALLAGHER. SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORPORAL. THE SERVER ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THANK. WELL CLOSER ALL
TIED ABOUT I. SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM. ONE SIXTY ONE IS S. B.
FIVE OH ONE. CORKERY SENATE
BILL FIVE A ONE BY CENTER BY
CAL SKI INOCULATING THE
GOVERNMENT A LIABILITY MR
MAIENSCHEIN EMAIL ME THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SB FIVE A ONE WHICH
CREATES AN EXTENSION TO THE
DEADLINE TO FILE A CLAIM
AGAINST A PUBLIC ENTITY IF THE
CLIMATE WAS A MINOR OR
INCAPACITATED FOR LESS THAN SIX
MONTHS AFTER THE INCIDENT SB
FIVE ONE HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I'VE
OF. THANK YOU MR MENTION. C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CARPOOL OF MORAL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERSOF. DESERVE VOTE. CLICK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY TWO SB FIVE OH FOUR CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL FIVE OH
FOUR BY SENATOR BACKER IN
ACCORDING TO ELECTIONS MR MAYS
YOU MAY OPEN. THE U. S.
SPEAKER- CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE
TO SHOW STRONG DESIRE TO IN
FRANCHISE JUSTICE INVOLVED IN
FORMALLY INCARCERATED VOTERS
BUT INCOMPLETE OR INACCURATE
INFORMATION THESE ELECTION
OFFICIALS MAKING EDUCATED
GUESSES. THEY TEND TO KEEP
VOTER REGISTRATION RECORDS UP
TO DATE SB FIVE OH FOUR WHEN
SURE BETTER MANAGEMENT JUST AS
INVOLVED CALIFORNIANS ARE IN
OUR VOTER ROLLS BY STREAMLINING
BASIC MAINTENANCE PROCESSES
BETWEEN CDC ARE. AND THE
SECRETARY OF STATE FOR THE MORE
AFTER COMPLETING A SENSE THE
COUNTY ELECTION OFFICE WE CAN
CONTACT FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PERSONS LETTING THEM KNOW THEY
ARE NOW ELIGIBLE TO REGISTER TO
VOTE. ADDITIONALLY MILITARY
OVERSEAS VOTERS AS WELL AS
VOTERS WITH DISABILITIES ARE
CURRENTLY PROHIBITED FROM
UTILIZING SAME DAY ARE
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE TO VOTERS
LIKE YOU AND ME THIS BILL FIXES
THAT THERE'S NO OPPOSITION IN
THE COUNTY CLERKS ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT. RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER MESS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CARP LOCAL ROLE. THE
SERVER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
RESIDED VOTE. WE HEAR THE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
AN ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES PAST RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY THREE.
MEMBERS AGAIN FILE IN ORDER
THIS IS ONE FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
FOUR. IF I WON SIXTY FOUR
SENATE BILL FIVE TWELVE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CORPORATE
WITH THE MESS SENATE BILL FIVE
TWELVE OF THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN MR
BERMAN ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY A RISE PERCENT
AMENDMENTS TO SB. FIVE TWELVE
THESE MOMENTS ADDRESS A
CONFLICT WITH ANOTHER BILL
AMENDING THE SAME CODE SECTION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MR BERMAN WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY THE I. SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT THE PRINTER
BACK ON FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY FIVE. SB FIVE THIRTY
THREE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORPORATE WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY THREE WITH THE MINUTES
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL MR
GABRIEL ON A MOMENT'S. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT ADD
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THANK
YOU. THANK WAS GABRIEL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT. VMEBUS ARE DOCTOR. BILLS
OUT TO PRINT BACK ON FILE FILE
ITEMS ONE. SIXTY SIX THROUGH
ONE SIXTY NINE PASS AND RETAIN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS CORKERY WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL FIVE
SEVENTY WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. MR
BERMAN AGAIN ON THE MEHMET'S.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES SB FIVE SEVENTY IS
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP OF
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE CODE
EQUIPMENT LIST THESE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS MAKE EXPLICITLY
CLEAR THAT THIS BILL APPLIES TO
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES EXCLUSIVELY
OPERATED BY THOMAS VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MISS BERMAN WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT MEMBERS
ARE DOCTOR BILLS OUT TO PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE FILES ONE
SEVENTY ONE THROUGH ONE SEVENTY
THREE. PASS AND RETAIN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FOUR SB
SIX THIRTY ONE. CORPORATE
SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACCOLADE
IN THE STATE CLAIMS A MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
DECLARING THERE'S A CEDAR UP
STICK FACT IMMEDIATELY. MS
GONZALEZ YOU MAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER S. B. SIX THIRTY
ONE IS REQUIRED TO BE CARRIED
BY THE CHAIR OF APPROPRIATIONS
IN EACH HOUSE. IT IS A CLAIMS
BILL WHAT IT IS THE EXPENDITURE
APPROPRIATION OF ONE POINT ONE
SIX FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD FOR
COMPENSATION OF WRONGFUL
IMPRISONMENT OF WILLIAM
RICHARDS. AND OTHER PRISONERS
SPENT NINETEEN YEARS BEHIND
BARS- AND- IS FACTUALLY
INNOCENT WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS CONSEILS. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE. WHO IS OUT
OF. WELL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE. THAT BILL
PASSES. WHERE TO PASS A
RETAINER FILE ITEM. ONE SEVENTY
FIVE. THROUGH. ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT. THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE
SEVENTY NINE. THIS IS MISS
FRIEDMAN. FILE ITEM ONE SEVEN
NINE SB SIX SEVENTY ONE CORKERY.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY ONE BY
THE CENTRE GONZALEZ AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION THIS FRIEDMAN
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ 2% SB
SIX SEVENTY ONE WHICH WOULD
CREATE A CLEAN FREE QUARTER
EFFICIENCY ASSESSMENT TO HELP
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE OF CLEAN
FREIGHT ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
FREIGHT IS THE BACKBONE OF OUR
ECONOMY MOVING TRILLIONSOF
DOLLARS OF GOODS THROUGH THE
STATE EACH YEAR EMPLOYING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND THE
TRANSPORTATION AND WAREHOUSING
SECTOR INDUSTRIES. FREE
QUARTERS HOWEVER OUR MAJOR
SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND AIR QUALITY
PROBLEMS FOR THE COMMUNITY
SURROUNDING THEM SB SIX SEVENTY
ONE TACKLES THIS ISSUE BY
REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION TO
COLLABORATE WITH OTHER RELEVANT
CITY AGENCIES TO DEVELOP
STRATEGIES I CAN TO CONVERT
EXISTING FREE QUARTERS INTO
CLEAN RECORDERS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON ADAM
LIBERAL. THIS ARTICLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF HER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CULTURAL TIES BUT I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTY
THREE ONE EIGHTY TWO. PASS AND
RETAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY THREE. SB SEVEN OH THREE
CORKERY. SENATE BILL SEVEN OH
THREE BY CENTER HER TADO AND
OTHERS IN THEIR LIVING TO
DECEASED ANIMALS MISTER SALAS
FEMALE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PRISON SB SEVEN OH
THREE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR HER
TADO THIS BILL ENSURES THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA LABORATORIES.
PERFORMING TESTS FOR SPECIFIED
REGULATORY DISEASES OR
CONDITIONS OF ANIMALS AND THEIR
PRODUCTS ARE MET ARE MEETING
STANDARDS SET BY. CALIFORNIA
CDFA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CELLS SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. SENATE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTY
FOUR THROUGH ONE NINETY ONE
PASS RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY TWO SB EIGHT OH ONE
CORPORATE. SENATE BILL EIGHT OH
ONE WITH A MINUTES BY SOME
REMEMBER LOW. YES HELLO ON THE
MINUTES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS SPEAKER RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR LOW WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT YOU MEMBERS ARE DR. BILLS
OUT THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEMS. ONE NINETY THREE.
THROUGH. ONE NINETY SEVEN. THIS
TAKES US TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY EIGHT. S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT CORKERY. SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION AN ACCURATE IN
STATE REAL PROPERTY IN MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION- FOR THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SB EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH SERVES AS THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE SURPLUS PROPERTY VAL.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
TO DISPOSE OF A NUMBER OF
PROPERTIES THAT TGS HAS
DETERMINED NO LONGER MEET OUR
STATE'S NAME. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THELEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU RESCUERS SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CORPORALS. ZERO ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS AT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A- CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TIME BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS. FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY NINE SB THREE OH TWO FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS COURT
AGREED WITH THE METS SENATE
BILL THREE OH TWO WITH A
MINUTES BY SOMEBODY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW MISTER BIGELOW
ON A MENACE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER A MINISTER SB THREE OH
TWO OR HERE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE. RESPECTFULLY. THANK YOU
MISS BIGELOW. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE I. SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED. THE BILL SOUGHT THE
PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
THERE IS
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED. AND
WE'RE GOING TO PASS. AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS TO A ONE. THROUGH.
TWO SIXTEEN. I SAY THAT WITH A
QUESTION MARK ON THE.
MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM TWO HUNDRED. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWO HUNDRED. SENATE BILL
TWO FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. THE CLERK WILL READ
WITH THE METS. SENATE BILL TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER DR WEBER ON THE
MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT THE
AMENDMENTS TO SENATE BILL TWO.
THESE AMENDMENTS CHANGE THE
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD SO
THAT IT IS NOT REQUIRED TO
FAMILY MEMBERS OF VICTIMS BUT
INSTEAD TO GENERAL MEMBERS WITH
CONSIDERATION OF THOSE MEMBERS.
REQUIRED TWO THIRDS VOTE TO
DECERTIFY CLARIFY THAT CLEAR
AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE IS
NEEDED TO DECERTIFY. VERIFY
THAT EXISTING LAW OF COLLATERAL
ESTOPPEL APPLIES IN REGARDS TO
ISSUE PRECLUSION CLARIFIES THE
GROUNDS FOR SERIOUS MISCONDUCT.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU DR WEBER WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY YES HAVE IT THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS UP TO
PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE. IN
PREVIOUS FOLLOWER I BELIEVE
WE'RE AT FILE ITEM TO
SEVENTEEN. FILE ITEM TO
SEVENTEEN IS SENATE BILL ONE OH
NINE CORPORATE. SENATE BILL ONE
OH NINE BY SENATOR DODD AND
OTHERS INCLUDING THE WILDFIRES
MR RODRIGUEZ YOU MAIL. THANK A
MISPRINT MEMBERS SB ONE ON ON
WITH ESTABLISHED THE OFFICE OF
WATER FAR TECHNOLOGY RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT WITHIN CAL
FIRE. CALIFORNIA FACES SOME OF
THE MOST COMPLEX AND SEVERE
WILDFIRE CONDITIONS IN THE
NATION. OUR CHALLENGE OF
GROWING A RECENT YEARS WITH
SEVENTEEN OF THE LARGER OF THE
TWENTY LARGEST FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY OCCURRING
SINCE TWO THOUSAND WITH SIX OF
THOSE LAST YEAR ALONE THIS
BURKE RATE IN OFFICE THAT WILL
SERVE AS THE CENTRAL ORGANIZING
HUB TO IDENTIFY EMERGING
WILDFIRE TECHNOLOGIES IN BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE THE WALL FAR TECHNOLOGY
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT REVIEW
BOARD TO ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND EFFICIENCY SB ONE I WOULD
LOVE TO WORK SMARTER TO PROTECT
OUR LIVES AND OUR COMMUNITIES A
RESPECT FOR US FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ C.
NOTIFICATION TODAY. TOP OF THE
ROLE- DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE- ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESERVE A. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS TO EIGHTEEN
THROUGH TWO TWENTY SEVEN. PASS
AND RETAIN. THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY EIGHT SB.
TWO NINETY NINE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS CORPORAL READ
WITH AMENDMENTS. SENATE BILL
TWO NINETY NINE WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME IMMIGRATION MISTER
GRAYSON ON MMS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AMENDMENTS TO SP TWO
NINETY NINE SIMPLY ADDRESSED
TRAPPING ISSUES RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANKS GRAYSON
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED. BILLS
OUT THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
FILE ITEMS. TWO TWENTY NINE.
THROUGH TWO THIRTY THREE PASS
AND RETAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWO THIRTY FOUR SB THREE THREE
NINE CORKERY SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY NINE BY CENTER WIENER
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE
VEHICLES MISS FRIEDMAN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SB
THREE THIRTY NINE IT'S SIMPLY
EXTENDS A PILOT PROGRAM THAT
WAS CREATED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHICH IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. TO BE EXTENDED THIS
IS STUDY THAT THE GAS TAX
ALTERNATIVE PILOT EXTENDS THE
ROAD CHARGE TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FROM TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE TO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY SEVEN AS WE TRANSITION
TO SAYS OF COURSE THE GAS TAX
BECOMES LESS RELEVANT PRISON
LESS INCOME TO THE STATE. AND
IN MANY WAYS IS A REGRESSIVE
TAX- IF IT CONTINUES SO THIS
WOULD HELP TO. CONTINUE THE
PILOT TO STUDY OTHER WAYS OF
COLLECTING REVENUE TO FUND OUR
HIGHWAY INFRASTRUCTURE- IT
WHICH WOULD BE A ROAD USER
CHARGE OF SOME SORT. OF WITH
THAT I REQUEST I'D I'D VOTE TO
CONTINUE THIS IMPORTANT STUDY
SO THAT WE HAVE BETTER DATA
MOVING FORWARD AS TO HOW TO PAY
FOR OUR ROAD INFRASTRUCTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN. ST NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. QUICKLAW THE ROLE.
RESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY ONE KNOWS FIFTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO THIRTY FIVE SB THREE
FIFTY FOUR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORPORATE WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTY FOUR THE MINUTES BY SOME
REMEMBER RUBIO THIS RUBIO ON
THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE AMENDMENTS TO SP
THREE FIFTY FOUR AT THE DESK
ARE TRAPPED DURING A MEN'S AND
TECHNICAL IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT. MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED. BILLS
AT THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE
THIS IS FILE ITEM TO THIRTY SIX.
SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS COURT
AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY SEVEN WITH A
MEMBERS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
OUR QUE HAN. MISSPELLED QUE HAN
ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THESE ARE
CHATTERING AMENDMENTS AND I
RESPECT THAT PRIVATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WOMEN TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYES.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES
HAVE IT THE REFERENCE OUR
DOCTOR. THE BILLS OUT OF
PRINTED BACK ON FILE. FILE
ITEMS TO THIRTY SEVEN AND TWO
THIRTY EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM. TWO THIRTY
NINE SB. THREE NINETY THREE.
ACCORDING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES MISTER CELIS YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE TO PRESENT SB THREE NINETY
THREE WHICH FIXES- FUNDING
ISSUES TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE FOR HARD
WORKING AGRICULTURAL FAMILIES
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER SALAS. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE-
JENNIFER ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIE THE VOTE
HIGHS FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHILE
WE- AWAIT SIGNALS FROM THE
SIDELINES WE ARE GOING TO BE.
DOING SO VOTE CHANGES. THESE
ARE VOTE CHANGES A LITTLE
SOONER THAN WE THOUGHT.
MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO ENTERTAIN VOTE
CHANGES. BEFORE WE BREAK FOR
LUNCH. DR CHOI YOUR VOTE CHANGE
THANK YOU FILE NUMBER ONE
THIRTEEN SB ONE. AVOID CHANGING
FROM THE OLD TOOL NOT LOADING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI SENATE BILL ONE NO TO NOT
VOTING. MISTER BENNETT FILE
ITEM NINETY NINE BILL SB FIVE
FIVE SIX FROM I DO NOT VOTING.
WILL CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY
SIX ALL RIGHTS ARE NOT VOTING.
AND MR FONG. OF FONG VOTE
CHANGE SB ONE I TO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG SENATE BILL ONE I TO NOT
VOTING. MISS GONZALES SB FIVE
FIFTY SIX I IT'S NOT VOTING.
PRO CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ SENATE BILL FIV FIFTY
SIX I TO NOT VOTING.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO BE TAKING A LUNCH
BREAK AT THIS TIME WE ARE GOING
TO BE TAKING A- BRIEF RECESS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
RECONVENING PROMPTLY AT. ONE
FIFTEEN. THAT DOES NOT MEAN ONE
THIRTY THAT MEANS ONE FIFTEEN
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR WILL
BE TAKING ITEMS UP AT. ONE
FIFTEEN- SEE THEM.
MEMBERS
PLEASE RETURN OF THE FLOOR WE
ARE TAKING UP ITEMS SHORTLY.
YEAH YEAH.
YEAH. WELL.
YEAH.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP ITEMS MOMENTARILY.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR.
IMMEDIATELY.
IF YOU WANT. TO- I.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM. TO
FORTY ONE. CORRECTION LET'S
MAKE THAT PASSED RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM TO FORTY ONE. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM TO FORTY TWO. MEMBERS
PLEASE RETURN OF THE FLOOR
RIGHT NOW.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP. THE ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM THIS ITEM THESE
ARE AMENDMENTS. THIS IS FILE
ITEM. TWO SEVENTY FOUR. FILE
ITEM TWO SEVENTY FOUR. SB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE OF THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN
IS BARRICADE HAND ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE FOR THE AMENDMENTS
ARE NON SUBSTANTIVE AND THEY
MERELY MAKE SURE WE MAKE AN
APPROPRIATE REFERENCE A RECENT
COURT CASE WITH THE CORRECT
CITATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS PARA
QUE HAN. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE I. SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE
DOCTOR. BILLS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS AND RETAIN. ON FILE ITEMS
TO FORTY THREE AND TWO FORTY
FOUR. AS WELL AS. TWO FORTY
FIVE. REGISTER FILE ITEM TO
FORTY SIX SB FOUR FIFTY SIX
CORPORATION SENATE BILL FOUR
FIFTY SIX BY CENTER LAYER AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO FIRE
PREVENTION. DR WOULD EMAIL THEM
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS RE CURRENT AND CURRENT
FIRES RECENT AND CURRENT FIRES
ARE DEVASTATING COMMUNITIES UP
AND DOWN THE STATE WE'RE SEEING
THE DEVASTATION RIGHT NOW IN
THE LAKE TAHOE REGION IS
ACCOUNT OR FIRE SPREADS- IT
WITH A HORRIBLE SPEED AND
DESTRUCTION. I SAW THE SAME
STE- THE DEVASTATION MY OWN
COMMUNITY. OF THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS IN RESPONSE TO THIS
DEVASTATION AND PROTECT
COMMUNITIES THE STATE HAS MADE-SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS WITH
STATE DOLLARS TO BUILD OUR
RESILIENCY WHEN IT COMES TO
WILDFIRES THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
NEEDED AND SO IS A LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ENSURE
TREATMENTS A PROGRESS AND
ACHIEVEMENTS ARE MADE AND
TRACKED. SB FOUR FIFTY SIX WILL
REQUIRE THE STATE TO ESTABLISH
A LONG TERM FIRE PREVENTION
ACTION PLAN TO ENSURE STATEWIDE
INVESTMENTS TO COMBAT BUYERS
ARE COMPREHENSIVE SCIENCE BASED
IN UTILIZED COMPLEMENTARY
PARTNERSHIPS FOR THE STATE'S
VARIOUS REGIONS THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THE STATE TO SUBMIT AN
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT INCLUDES
PROGRESS EXPENDITURES AND
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND POLICY
CHANGES NEEDED TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS OF THE ACTION PLAN. THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
AND HAS ENJOYED MARC BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES- THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB FOUR FIFTY SIX. MR
RODRIGUEZ YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK RESPECT AMERICA'S I RISE
ALSO SUPPORTED SB FOUR FIFTY
SIX. THIS BILL PROVIDES A LONG
OVERDUE FRAMEWORK TO SUPPORT
LOCAL FARMERS REDUCTION AND
ADAPTATION PROGRAMS. AS WE HAVE
SEEN IN RECENT YEARS AND
ESPECIALLY NOW OUR STATE IS
INCREASINGLY VULNERABLE TO
WILDFIRES. AMONG THESE EFFORTS
THE WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE TASK FORCE WE WILL
UTILIZE. FUEL REDUCTION
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND RED
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT TO
PROTECT LIVES PROPERTY WILDLIFE
AND WATER SUPPLY. I ALSO
RESPECT OFTEN AYE VOTE ON SB
FOUR FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU MISS
RODRIGUEZ SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. DR WHEN
YOU MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU WISH
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE A
COUPLE OF THE ROLE. IT IS AT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO BE. TAKING UP
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. WE ARE GOING
TO BE TAKING- ASSEMBLY BELLS ON
CONCURRENCE. THIS IS
CONCURRENCE AND SEVEN
AMENDMENTS WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY. ON FILE ITEMS.
THREE FOUR AND. FIVE I. WHAT A
PASSWORD CANNOT FILE ITEM SIX.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN. THIS IS AB. SIX
ONE SIX BY MISTER STONE THE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
INTO LABOR RELATIONS MR STONE
AVAILABLE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SIX ONE SIX
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE WITH
SENATE AMENDMENTS SENTIMENTS
ARE MINOR TECHNICAL. I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
MICHELLE C. NOTIFICATION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM CLARK
LIBERAL. THE CEREMONY ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
MEMBERS WE ARE RESUMING ADAMS
PLEASE RETURN OF FLORAL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A IS FORTY
TWO DOES FOURTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. MS
GONZALES HAS THREE ITEMS. THIS
IS THE TOP OF THE CONCURRENT
FILE. BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE THIS IS AB. TWO
EIGHTY SIX. THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AND OTHERS AND ACCORDING TO
BUSINESS. THIS GONZALEZ EMAIL
BUT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWO EIGHTY SIX BACK ON
CONCURRENT SENATE MOMENTS
REQUIRE FOOD DELIVERY COMPANIES
TO PROVIDE A GENERAL NOTICE TO
CUSTOMERS AT A RESTAURANT PAYS
A FEE OR COMMISSION TO THE
THIRD PARTY DELIVERY COMPANY.
AND REQUIRE A COMPLETE PICTURE
OF THE FEES CONSUMERS PAY ON A
TRANSACTION TO BE GIVEN TO THE
FOOD FACILITY THIS BILL O
LONGER REQUIRES RESTAURANTS TO
DISCLOSE TO THE CUSTOMERS
ITEMIZE FEES AND COMMISSIONS
THEY PAY A FOOD DELIVERY
COMPANY IF THE RESTAURANT
CHOOSES NOT TO- THESE
AMENDMENTS ALSO MADE OF VARIOUS
CLARIFYING CHANGES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK GOODNESS AND SALAS
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM THE CORPORAL OF THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT. WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I FORTY FIVE NO
SEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS. OKAY
KURT IN THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOR AB FIVE OH SIX FOR
COREY. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ AND ACTUALLY INTERVIEW
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS THIS
GONZALEZ EMAIL. THANK YOU AB
FIVE SEXES BACK ON CONCURRENCE%
IT HELP PREVENT CHILD ABUSE BY
REQUIRING YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS
TO IMPLEMENT SPECIFIED CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION MATT MEASURES
INCLUDING BACKGROUND CHECKS AND
TRAINING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THERE WAS
CONVULSING DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORPORAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE OF IT I FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN AND THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIVE AB EIGHT EIGHT ONE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS AND
ACCORDING TO SOLID WASTE THIS
GONZALEZ YOU MAY GET OPEN.
THANK YOU AB EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND
AMENDMENTS OUT OF REPORTING ON
THE JURISDICTION OF ORIGIN OF
THIS WASTE FOR PURPOSES OF
IMPLEMENTATION THIS WOULD CLOSE
A LOOPHOLE IN CALIFORNIA LAW
THAT LETS EXPORTED MIXED
PLASTIC WASTE BE COUNTED AS
RECYCLED EVEN WHEN IT IS NOT-
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BILL NAY
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT HAS
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THEY RISK
IT'S ALSO INNER DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
DESERVE A. CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ISIS SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM. SIX WITH THE
SPECIFIED- SEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM EIGHT.
SPRINGS JUST FOLLOW NINE AB TEN
THIRTY ONE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA GOOGLE AND
OTHERS ARE NOT GOING TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT THE SURVEY APPROVED
BY. THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS
MISTER SPEAKER AB TEN THIRTY
ONE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THIS THE SENATE NIMITZ- FURTHER
CLARIFICATION OF PROVISIONS FOR
THIS BILL A. B. TEN THIRTY ONE
WILL HELP SIR SURVIVORS AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SEEK
UNEMPLOYMENT. HELP THEM FROM
FALLING BACK INTO THAT
LIFESTYLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CABALLERO ALL MEMBERS OF
THE CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESERT ABOUT. CLARK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT AYE
SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IT THIS IS FILE
ITEM TEN AB FOURTEEN OH TWO.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO
TO BUY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE
AN ACT RELATING TO TAXATION. MR
LEVINE EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IN COLLEGE AB FOURTEEN
OH TWO IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
FOR CONCURRENCE THE BILL WILL
STANDARDIZE THE COLLECTION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT P. FEES ON
CERTAIN RETAIL PRODUCTS SOLD.
BY MARKETPLACE FACILITATORS IN
CALIFORNIA SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES
TO THE EXISTING FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION FEES
IN THE FEE COLLECTION
PROCEDURES LAW. WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL OPPOSITION HAS
BEEN REMOVED AND NO MEMBERS
SHALL BE SUSPENDED I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. I
HEARD THAT I WAS PAYING
ATTENTION. THANK YOU
RESERVATIONS HE NOTICED CASH IN
THE BANK. CARCLUB THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS THAT VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AND VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENT ABOUT. CARDWELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY
NO SEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COULD CURTAIN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ELEVEN AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
NINE. THIS IS MR STONE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AND ACT
LIKE IT'S A FAMILY LAW MR STONE
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS IS OUR ANNUAL FAMILY
LAW I'M THE BEST BILL THE
AMENDMENTS ARE FOR CHAPTER RING
OUT SO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ON SENATE AMENDMENT. FAMOUS
DON'T SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN. IS OUT OF IT
ALL MEMBERS OF THE SENATE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. CLOSER TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. I
HAVE YESOD FILE ITEM TWELVE
THIS IS F. I. TWELVE AB TWENTY
SIX. OPERATOR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN AN ACT RELATING TO PEACE
OFFICERS MR HOLDEN THE MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER CHAIR
AB TWENTY SIX THE BILL THAT
PROVIDES UNIVERSAL MEASURES
THAT ESTABLISH WHAT IT MEANS
FOR A POLICE OFFICER TO
INTERVENE WHEN WITNESSING
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE BY
ANOTHER PEACE OFFICER IS BACK
OFF FOR CONCURRENCE. IMAGE
TAKEN IN THE SENATE WAS
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING IN
NATURE. I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO THANK ALL OF OUR GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS FOR THEIR
PERSISTENT ADVOCACY EFFORTS TO
KEEP THIS LEGISLATION MOVING.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK LAW
ENFORCEMENT. FOR TAKING ME UP
ON MY OFFER AND WILLINGNESS TO
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH WITH
THEM TO BRING THIS MEANINGFUL
LEGISLATION TO FRUITION. OUR
NEGOTIATIONS HAVE REMOVED
OPPOSITION TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION FROM CHP. PORAC LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE
LEAGUE SACRAMENTO COUNTY DEPUTY
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION. AND
NUMEROUS POLICE OFFICER
ASSOCIATIONS SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATIONS AND DEPUTY
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN
A PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN WE HAVE A ONE DAY
WAITING PERIOD TO TAKE THIS
ITEM UP SO I APPRECIATE THAT
PRESENTATION. WE MAY HAVE TO
HAVE YOU DO THAT AGAIN TOMORROW-
AND THEN WE WILL TAKE A VOTE AT
THAT TIME. DID A HELLUVA JOB
THE PRESS. OKAY WE'RE GOING TO
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
THIRTEEN. THROUGH. TWENTY ONE.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO. MISTER CHOW YOUR
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION. YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE SIXTY NINE TO ALLOW
SOMEONE MEMBER RADIOS TO TAKE
UP LATE FLOOR AMENDMENTS TO
ITEM. SEVENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR. MR FLOOR FOR
PURPOSE SIR HE WAS A SPEAKERWE
WERE HOLDING HANDS CONSENT HAS
ROLL CALL VOTE MISTER FLORA IS
WITHHOLDING. MISTER CHOW MOSES
PARA QUE HAN SECONDS. ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE. THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE MARK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE MR CHOW IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. AND MR FLORA IS
ASKING FOR A NOVO THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. MISTER CHOW IS
ASKING FOR A NIGHT AND- MR
FLORIDA NO.
WELL CLOSE ROLE AS
FIFTY THREE NO SEVENTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE UP A- BILL ON
SENATE THIRD READING. THIS IS
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM.
TWO OH THREE. FILE ITEM TWO OH
THREE SB. NINETEEN AND THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
NINETEEN BY SERVER GLACIER AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. IS PARA
QUE HAN YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL NINETEEN BY
SENATOR GLAZER WHICH WOULD
ALLOW LICENSED WINE AND BRANDY
MANUFACTURERS HAVE OPTED TO
OFFSITE TASTING ROOMS YES
MEMBERS WERE INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF OFF SITE TASTING
ROOMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS GOOD FOR
BUSINESS AND GOOD FOR OUR SMALL
WINE GROWERS. WHO AT THIS
MOMENT IN TIME NEED TO HELP TO
GET THROUGH THIS DIFFICULT
PANDEMIC. UNDER EXISTING LAW
TIED TO WINDER LICENSEES ARE
ALLOWED TO TASTING ROOMS ONE ON
SITE AT THE PRODUCTION FACILITY
AT A SECOND LOCATION OFF SITE
HOWEVER. MANY OPERATE UNDER AN
AGREEMENT THAT ALLOWS A
WINEMAKER TO PRODUCE THEIR WINE
USING ANOTHER. WINERIES
PRODUCTION FACILITIES WHICH
MEANS THOSE WINERIES OPERATING
UNDER THESE AGREEMENTS ARE
PROHIBITED FROM HAVING A TASTER
ROOM AT THEIR PRODUCTION
FACILITY. AS WE ALL KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA WINE INDUSTRY HAS
BEEN CHALLENGED BY BILLIONS IN
LOST REVENUES DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. AND THE WILD FIRES
THE BILL BENEFITS ALL
CALIFORNIA WINERIES BIG AND
SMALL BY GIVING THEM THE OPTION
OPEN ONE MORE OFF SITE TASTING
ROOM. SB NINETEEN IS A
BIPARTISAN MEASURE THAT HAS NO
NO VOTES AND IS SUPPORTED BY A
COALITION. OF WINERIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AMERICA HAVE.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS SHOULD RESERVE A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ADEBOYE
VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS
THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A FILE
ITEM. TWO FORTY FILE ITEM TO
FORTY SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
FIVE. CORKERY SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY FIVE BY CENTER CABALLERO
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTHY OUTCOMES AND PREVENTION
EDUCATION ACT AND MAKING A
PROVISION OR FOR DOCTOR
ARAMBULA YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE AS A PROUD PRINCIPLE CO
AUTHOR OF SB THREE NINETY FIVE
WHICH PROPOSES CLOSER TAX
PARITY BETWEEN VAPING AND
TRADITIONAL TOBACCO PRODUCTS BY
ENACTING A TWELVE AND A HALF
PERCENT RETAIL TAX COLLECTED
FROM THE PURCHASER. AT THE
POINT OF SALE. VAPING HAS BEEN
PLAGUING OUR YOUTH AND OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR YEARS AND IF
LEFT UNCHECKED WILL CONTINUE TO
DO HARM FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME. TO BACK- RETAILERS ARE
MORE PREVALENT IN THE POOREST
AND MOST ETHNICALLY DENSE
NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH INCLUDE
POPULATIONS MOST AT RISK OF
INADEQUATE HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND COVERAGE. BY CLOSING THIS
LOOPHOLE IN A TOBACCO PRODUCTS
TAX THESE PROCEEDS WILL BE USED
TO FUND SAFETY NET SERVICES AND
PROVIDE GRANTS TO STUDENTS FROM
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS
PURSUING AN EDUCATION IN THE
HEALTH FIELD. TO COMBAT THE
LONG TERM NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. THREE NINETY
FIVE IS SUPPORTED BY A LARGE
COALITION OF ADVOCATES HAS HAD
NO OPPOSITION OR MEMBERS VOTING
NO AND WILL AID IN THE FIGHT TO
CURTAIL USE VAPING. WHILE
HELPING TO CONTINUE SUPPORT
CRITICAL PROGRAMS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
REGULAR. SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM LEVEL OF
MORAL ALL MEMBERS OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENT
ABOUT.
WELL POSE A ROLE. TYLER
HIGHS FIFTY SEVEN NO SIX
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN TWO WAY TO ONE
DAY WAITING PERIOD FOR
CONCURRENCE ITEMS TWELFTH
THROUGH SIXTY SEVEN INCLUSIVE
TO ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE UP
THEIR ASSEMBLY BILL TODAY. HEY
MISTER FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR HE
WAS SPEAKING WITH HOLDING OUT
CONSENT AS A ROLL CALL OF MR
FLOOR IS WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. MISTER SHABBOS M. AS
PARA QUE HAN SECONDS ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE CLERK
WILL. OPEN THE ROLE. MISTER
CHOW'S ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND MR FLOORS ASKING FOR NO
VOTE. MISTER CHALICE ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. AND MR FLORA'S
ASKING FOR NO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ROLE HIGHS FIFTY
FOUR NO SIXTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO BE TAKING UP CONCURRENCE
ITEMS.
K. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO BE TAKING UP CONCURRENCE
ITEMS. YOU'LL RECALL THAT MR
HOLDEN PRESENTED ON HIS MEASURE
MR HOLDEN. MR HOLDEN IF YOU
WOULD KINDLY BE PREPARED TO
SUMMARIZE YOUR PREVIOUS
PRESENTATION THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWELVE AB TWENTY SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY GOAL TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND I
BELIEVE IN THE PEACE OFFICERS
MR HOLDEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIX IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE I CONCURRENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SIR SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLARK WILL OFFER THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF THE SIDE OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE OF HIGHS FORTY SIX KNOWS
THIRTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CAN CURTAIN.
MEMBERS ON THE
CONCURRENT FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE A FILE ITEM SEVENTY
THREE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE. AB.
SIX FIFTY
FOUR. MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
FOUR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
COURT AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY FOUR
WITH A MEMBERS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS. MITHRAS ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO EIGHTY
SIX FIVE FOR. WHICH ARE
EXPECTED TO REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION WILL EVEN MOVE THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND OTHERS
OF THE OPPOSITION COALITION TO
SUPPORT POSITION. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. FAMOUS
RESTAURANT THAT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT NEW MEMBERS
ARE NOT THE BILLS OUT THE
PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS
WE ARE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS WHO
ARE READY TO TAKE UP THEIR
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. THIS COULD
GET CRAZY. BOB WEIR AND FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN LET'S TRY THIS
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWO SIXTY
THREE DR ARAMBULA SEEMS READY
TO OPERATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SIXTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AND OTHERS AND I
TELLING THE PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES AND CLEARLY ZERO
THICK THICK MEDIALLY. DECORATED
I EMAILED ME THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWO
SIXTY THREE IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DR RAMOS. I'M
SORRY MR. I SEE. YES THANK YOU
SIR. THIS IS GONNA BE FUN. SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERICAL OF THE ROLE MEMBERS
RIGHT INSIDE OF US. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENT ABOUT. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE OF ICE FIFTY
SIX NO ZERO. SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE WANT
TO JUMP TO FILE ITEM NINETEEN.
AB. FOUR SEVENTY FOUR. BY MR
CHILD CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOWING
ACCORDING TO PUBLIC RECORDS
MISTER SHALL BE AVAILABLE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL.
MISTER JEFFERSON ON.
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY FOUR WITH
THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. FEDERAL TITLE BUT I
SIXTEEN OH ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
OKAY WE DO HAVE ANOTHER. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. EIGHTEEN AB FOUR
SEVENTY THREE CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR SEVENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC RECORDS
MISTER CHOW YOU MAIL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS SPEAKER EIGHTY
FOUR SEVENTY THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE I ASKED WHERE I GO
THANK YOU. WITH THAT CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN. AB
THREE EIGHTY ONE COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE EIGHTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES AND
OTHERS ACTUALLY INTO SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER THIS DAVIS YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
THREE EIGHTY ONE WHICH IS BACK
IN CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS ADDED
NEW TYPES OF LIFESAVING FDA
APPROVED DRUGS THAT CAN BE USED
A DRUG TREATMENT CENTERS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT A
VOTE. THANK YOU. AMOS DAVIS C.
DISCUSSION DEBATE LOCAL OF THE
ROLE. ZERO ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLLTIDE ABOUT EYES
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE PREFERRED IN.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA TAKE A FILE
ITEM TWENTY AB FIVE FORTY THREE
BY MISS DAVIES. QUACKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES AND
OTHERS IMMACULATE IN THE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION MISS DAVIS
YOU MAY GET OPEN THANK MISTER
SPEAKER GOOD AFTERNOON TODAY
I'M HERE 2% EIGHTY FIVE FOUR
THREE WHICH IS BACK IN
CONCURRENCE TECHNICALS SUDDEN
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORTED
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS DAVIS SANDO DISCUSSED
HER BAIT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THE SENATE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO. FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO BY MISS CALDERON. THIS IS
AB SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT ACCORDING
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON ACCOLADES JUVENILES
THIS CALDERON YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE OF SENATE
AMENDMENTS SENATE AMENDMENTS
FURTHER CLARIFY THE MEANING OF
PASSIVE RESISTANCE AND PROVIDE
DOUBLE JOINTING LANGUAGE THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MISS
CALDERON SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. WELL OPEN ROLE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SERVICE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS. ARKIN CURTIS
IS FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE. AB
SEVEN EIGHTY NINE. CALGARY
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LO AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE HEALTHCARE SERVICES
MISTER L<c.cyan>G AVAILABLE THANK</c>
YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKING
COLLEAGUES EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
NINE HELPS TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE GREATER HEALTH CARE
SCREENING I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RANDOM. THANK YOU MISTER LO SI
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS FOLKS WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR. EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
BY ISTER ROBERTS CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROMMEL'S AND
OTHERS AN ALKYLATING TO
VEHICLES MISTER RAMOS YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE FROM
THE SENATE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT AUTHORIZES PHILLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES TO OPERATE
INSPECT MAINTAIN AND DRIVE
EMERGENCY VEHICLES WITHIN
TRIBAL LANDS I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS RUNNING
SENIOR DISCUSSION A BANK CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IS THERE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. THE REQUESTED OKAY
OKAY WORK WELL YEAH HOUSE
ROLLTIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN. ON. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB EIGHT OH
SEVEN. QUACKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT OH SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AND
APPLICANTS OF OUR PRODUCTS AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
TO CLEAR THE YEARS HEATER OF
STICK FACT MEDIA BE. MISTER
GRAYSON EMAIL OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT
ZERO SEVEN INCREASES. BAR
PILOTAGERATES MODERNIZES THE
PROCESS TO ADJUST ATES IN
RESPONSE TO CATASTROPHIC COST
INCREASES AUTHORIZES PILOTS TO
CREATE CATASTROPHIC EVENT
MEMORANDUM ACCOUNTS. AND
IMPOSES TEMPORARY MOVEMENT FEES
TO RECOVER COSTS THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE WOULD
ADDITIONALLY UPDATE. AND
INCREASED BAR PILOTAGE RATES
AND IMPOSED TEMPORARY MOVEMENT
FEES FOR VESSELS USING POLITICS
SERVICES TO RECOVER COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATING
EXPENSES INCURRED DURING COVERT
NINETEEN. A. B. EIGHT ZERO
SEVEN HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IT IS OUT OF A
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS OUT OF.
WELL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY FIVE NEWS HERE
ON THE MEASURE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
AND MR BLOOM ARE YOU READY TO.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FIVE TWENTY
SIX THIS IS MR SANTIAGO FILE
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN A. B. TEN
TWENTY FOUR. COOKERY ILLEGAL
TEN TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO AND OTHERS
IMMACULATE IN A HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCE. MR SANTIAGO THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
MEASURES BACK FOR CONCURRENT
CERTAIN THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE TECHNICAL BY NATURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU TO SANTIAGO SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
THE HIGH SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IN.
YEAH MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT AB ELEVEN
FORTY NINE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN FORTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER VIA FOOD WINE
ACCOLADES ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
TO DECLARE THE URGENCY TO
RUSTIC BACK IMMEDIATELY IT
SHOULD BE APPROVED WHAT. THINGS
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB ELEVEN FORTY
NINE IS BACK FOR THE CURRENTS.
SENATE MINUTES ADDS THE URGENCY
CLAUSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR BE
PUT SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRABLE. WELL CULTURAL CALVET
I SIXTY FIVE KNOWS YOU'RE ON
THE URGENCY I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE THAT BILL
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TWENTY NINE. FILE ITEM. TWENTY
NINE. AB TWELVE NINETY THREE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY AND OTHERS AND ACCORDING
TO RETIREMENT MR COOLEY EMAIL
BUT. COLLEAGUES AB TWELVE
NINETY THREE DEALS WITH
PERSONALIZED RULES AFFECTED THE
JUDGE'S RETIREMENT SYSTEMS TO
UNDERSTATE LAW. AND INTERACT
WITH FEDERAL LAW WHICH AFFECTS
THE BENEFIT PAYABLE REQUIRES AN
ADJUSTMENT- THIS IS NON
CONTROVERSIAL MEASURES COME FOR
THE BODY OF VARIOUS TIMES AS
FEDERAL CHANGE URGENT AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS COOLEY. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CARCLUB
THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF A I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM THIRTY.
ASCERTAIN A FILE ITEM THIRTY
ONE. PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEMS THIRTY TWO AND. THIRTY
THREE. IN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM. THIRTY FOUR. AB
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR COOKERY
SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE AND FOOD
DELIVERY MISTER LATE EMAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER%
MEMBERS FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR AB
FORTY FORTY FOUR IS BACK IN
CONCURRENCE IT ENSURES THAT
FOOD DEALER PLATFORMS IN ONLINE
DIRECTORIES RIGHT AFTER
BUSINESS INFORMATION AND IS
ESPECIALLY SMALL BUSINESSES
CONTINUE TO SURVIVE IN A
PANDEMIC ECONOMY ONLINE IS A
BOARD TO HAVE PROTECTIONS FOR
THEM AND THAT'S WHY IT IS
SUPPORTED BY MANY IN THE
CONSUMER RIGHTS AND BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EITHER A CONCURRENCE. THANK
YOU MISTER LEE. SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. OR CALL THE
ROLL. IS THERE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY NINE KNOWS SIX SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. THIRTY FIVE. AB
FIFTEEN ELEVEN. QUIVERING
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN ELEVEN BY
THE COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE AND
ARE LOOKING FOR INSURANCE MR
DAILY EMAIL BUT MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS IS THE ANNUAL
INSURANCE COMMITTEE OMNIBUS
BILL IT CONTAINS NON
CONTROVERSIAL PROPOSALS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MR DAILY WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE SIR. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I AM GOING TO RE
REFER ITEM THIRTY FIVE AB
FIFTEEN ELEVEN TO THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE. THAT'S CERTAINLY
FINE THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
NEVER SEEN FILE ORDER. WE ARE
AT FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE BY THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
AND I BELIEVE CHILD CARE DOCTOR
WOULD BE AVAILABLE BILL IS BACK
IN CONCURRENCE WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD SAY NO DISCUSSION. WHERE
DEBATE CARPAL OF THE ROLE.
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
WILL DECIDE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS
PERCENT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I AM
REFERRING ITEM FIFTY ONE. AB
EIGHT SIXTEEN Q. TO THE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE.
WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME OF THE ONE TWENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND OTHERS YOU
KNOW GOING TO VEHICLES AS PART
OF OUR BACK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YES THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB ONE TWENTY TWO WOULD
MAKE INTERSECTIONS SAFER FOR
BIKE RIDERS DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS. BY ALLOWING BIKE
RIDERS TO TREAT STOP SIGNS AS
YIELD SIGNS WHEN APPROACHING
THE INTERSECTION AND IT IS SAFE
TO DO SO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ADD DETAILS FOR WHAT'S REQUIRED
BY THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE. ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN ON THE
SAFETY FRONT FOR THE BILL AND
THEY PROVIDE CHANGES TO ME BY
THE THIS BILL SHALL NOT AFFECT
THE LIABILITY OF A DRIVER OF A
MOTOR VEHICLE AS A RESULT OF
DRIVER'S NEGLIGENCE OR WRONGFUL
ACTION OR OMISSION. IN THE
OPERATION OF A MOTOR VEHICLE
AND THREE MAKE TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING CHANGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MISTER LACK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE MATTER. YOUR MEMBERS I'M
SORRY TO STAND BUT THE THIS TO
ME AS A AS A VERY- TOXIC BILL-
BECAUSE IT HAS TO DO WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND I WOULD SAY
THAT IT'S GOING TO CREATE
CONFUSION FOR MOTORISTS NOT
THAT THEY'RE NOT A CONFUSED
ALREADY- IT INCLUDES HIGHER
SPEED ELECTRIC BICYCLES THEY GO
UP TO THIRTY MILES AN HOUR. BOB
THAT'S ENOUGH IMPACT BECAUSE
VERY VERY SERIOUS PROBLEMS.
FINALLY IT JUST UNDERMINES THE
IMPORTANCE OF STOP SIGNS PEOPLE
ALREADY HAVING TROUBLE
ACKNOWLEDGING STOP SIGNS AND
THE IMPORTANCE THEY PLAY AND
THIS CREATES. THANK YOU MISTER
LACKING MISTER SMITH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL I'VE
BEEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
VICTOR VALLEY BICYCLE TOUR FOR
THE LAST FIVE YEARS. WHAT WE'VE
BEEN TEACHING THE KIDS TWO
REGARDING THE SCHOOL'S OF
BICYCLE SAFETY CLASSES IN THE
BIGGEST ONE IS TO STOP AT A
STOP SIGN. YOU WILL NOT COMPETE
WITH THE CAR ON YOUR BICYCLE.
AGAINST ANY VEHICLE I URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER SMITH
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER IS
BOERNER HORVATH YOU MAKE THOSE
YES THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THE
DATA HAS SHOWN THAT IN CITIES
AS LARGE AS THE AUTO AND RURAL
AREAS AS WELL. WE'VE BEEN BY
SPURS CAN TREAT STOP SIGNS AS
YIELD SIGNS. THE EVERYBODY IN
THE INTERSECTION OF FAVORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL ARE THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IN THEIR DROVES THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. YEAH.
CALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY THREE
NO SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE
CONCURRENT SENATE CURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENT. SENTIMENTS
ARE CONVERTED. FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE EIGHTY THREE TWENTY TWO
THE COURT AGREED. SOME PEOPLE
THREE TWENTY TWO BY SOME OF THE
SOLACE AND OTHERS AND ACCORDING
TO ENEGY. THIS IS ALICE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
THREE TWENTY TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE TO
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES ON THE
SENATE FLOOR RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL CALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS THAT YOU DESERVE IT.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALENT VOTE HIGHS FIFTY NINE IS
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FORTY AB
FOR TWENTY EIGHT THE
CORPORATION. SOME PEOPLE FOR
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES AND ACCORDING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ESTIMATES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THE
UNITED SPEAKER- EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
RESPECTED BECAUSE AND I HAVE A-
SEEN HERE IN NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR- ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
AMERICA. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
THE VOTE EYES FORTY TWO NEWS
TEN THAT MEASURE- SENATE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED.
FILE ITEM FORTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTY FIVE AGUIAR-CURRY. SOME
PEOPLE FOR SIXTY FIVE BRIAN SO
MEMBERS AREA AMERICA IN THE
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS
MISTER TERRY AND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER- EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTY FIVE IS BACK ON THE FLOOR
FOR CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. INCLUDE THE
FREQUENCY OF CONTINUATION OF
EDUCATION INSTRUCTIONS AS WELL
AS TWO HOURS AT LEAST TWO HOURS
ON FX. I RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT FIFTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
COMPLETED I NEED. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY
CHIU AB FOR SIXTY EIGHT THE
CORPORATE. SOME PEOPLE FOR
SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS AND I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT ANIMALS THREE
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER- AB FOR SIXTY
DAYS BACK FROM THE SENATE
CONCURRENCE THE MEMBERS ARE
CLARIFYING IN NATURE THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO NO VOTES. IT'S
SIMPLY A PREVENTS FRAUD IN THE
SERVICE DOG- WORLD AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER. DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
PAUL MEMBERS WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE A.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TELEVOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN WE
WILL TAKE UP. WE WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN ON THE
CONCURRENCE FILE. AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOR THE COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN TWENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
I PLAYED TO SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEMS THREE MEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
STAR FROM THE SENATE ON
CURRENTS IT IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE CLARIFYING IN
NATURE AND I REQUEST. PRESS
FULLY WHATEVER PLEASE VOTE I
THINK YOU. BEING A HEARING OVER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ROLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
TOMORROW. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY THAT ICD NINE
NEWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM S. SIXTY SEVEN. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN
FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS AND I
REALLY INTO SALES MISREADING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YET AGAIN
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AT THIS
IS ANOTHER BILL THAT'S RECEIVE
NO NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION OF THE AMENDMENTS
MADE TO THE BILL REMOVES THE
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENT FOR
WHETHER THE TICKET OR TICKETS
ARE NON TRANSFERABLE TO A THIRD
PARTY. AND WE ADDED A CO AUTHOR
WITH THAT I REQUEST AND I DON'T
THINK YOU. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE YEAH.
BURKE WELL ROLE IN TELLING VOTE
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED IN.
MOVING THE FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE EIGHTY FOUR NINETY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOMETHING
BEFORE NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADES HOUSING MR WARD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER A BEFORE NINETY ONE IS
BACK FOR CURRENCY SENTIMENTS
ARE TYPICAL AND CLEAR AND- IN
NATURE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. CALL
MEMBERS VOTED. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT I. SIXTY NEW ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO FIVE
THIRTY FIVE BY SOME MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE FOOD LABELING MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
THE SENATE NOW DISCLOSURE LABEL
ON ALL OF WILL CONTAINERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
C. AND HEARING FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL. CALL MEMBERS
VOTED EITHER. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD OF. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLADEGA
HIGHS FIFTY FIVE NEWS ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME OF THE FIVE
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN APPLING TO
JUVENILES MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB BY FORTY SIX IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE RESTRICTION BILL FOR
CLARITY IN ADDED CHAPLAIN OUT
LANGUAGE EXPECT THE REQUEST AND
I'VE SEEN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. CALL
MEMBERS. WHO DO THEIR TO THE-
HOME VOTED DESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED ESERVER. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING VOTE I
SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE SIX FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FIVE SIXTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY AND OTHER PERSONALITIES
REPLENISH. YOUR RECOGNIZED
HELLO MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS OF
THIS BILL IS A MAN IN THE
SENATE WITH CONSIDERATION
DEPARTMENTAL NEEDS FOR TRACKING
DATA THIS LEGISLATION WILL ADD
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO THE INTERAGENCY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
APPRENTICESHIPS ARE CREATED
SUBCOMMITTEE TO STUDY
OPPORTUNITIES AFFORDED TO
FORMER FOSTER AND RECENTLY
HOMELESS YOUTH. THE SIXTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S. DEPENDENCY SYSTEM
BELONG TO US ALL. THE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO DIVERSITY THAT WILL
FOREVER ALTER THEIR SENSE OF
SECURITY THIS BILL AIMS TO
CONNECT THEM WITH EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY. APPRENTICESHIPS
ENABLE ON THE JOB TRAINING. AND
EARNING AN INCOME WHILE
PURSUING ADVANCED EDUCATION
OFTEN SIDESTEPPING DEPT. THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FLOURISH IN A
CAREER AND MAINTAIN EMPLOYABLE
SKILLS WHILE PURSUING THEIR
PASSION I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE A. WORK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT I
SIXTY FOUR NINE ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING. TO FILE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX TWENTY THREE
THE KERKORIAN. SOME PEOPLE SIX
TWENTY THREE BY THE COMMITTEE
ON AGRICULTURE AND ALKYLATING
TO AGRICULTURE. MISTER REVERSE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER-
THIS LEGISLATION MAKES A NUMBER
OF US IN TECHNICAL CHANGES
REGARDING STATE THERE ARE BOARD
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA APPLE.
COMMISSION THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE MINOR AND
TECHNICAL NATURE RESPECT THAT'S
WHEN I VOTE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER INVESTING IN HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER- WELL OPEN THEIR OWN.
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS ERICA. MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE THOSE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALITHA I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING THE
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT EIGHTY
SIX SIXTY FIVE AGUIAR-CURRY
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
NOT GOING TO CARE FACILITIES MR
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES TO BUILD
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
RESPECTFULLY ASK. RIVAL THANK
YOU MR GARCIA SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER OF
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE-
HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
GO. HOME MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND HOWEVER I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FORTY NINE EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ CYNICAL SIX SEVENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND
OTHERS NOT RELATING TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE MISTER SALAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB SIX SEVENTY THREE IS
THAT FOR PROPONENTS DEALS WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE THANK YOU MISTER
SALAS SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR- CALL MEMBERS
VOTED IN THERE TO MOVE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIGN TO VOTE.
MEMBERS VOTED AS ARE THOSE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
THE CORPORATION SENATE BILL
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN AND
OTHERS AND ACCORDING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. A SENATE AMENDMENT
IN IT AMENDMENTS INCLUDE-
ANNUAL REPORTING REQUIREMENT
WHICH MAKE THIS BILL EVEN
STRONGER RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
HIGH VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
NONMEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE TO ROLLING
TALITA I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONSIDERED ON WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM FIFTY
ONE MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
TWO AB EIGHT FIFTY THE
CORPORATION SOME PEOPLE EIGHT
FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE IT'S A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT- YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. IS THE COMMAND
SPEAKER MEMBERS- EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
IN ALLOWS A- THREE CITIES THE
CITIES OF EL MONTE MONTEBELLO
AND WILLOW'S. ADD TO
CONSOLIDATE THEIR WATER
SYSTEMS- EXTENDS THE DEADLINE
FOR THEM TO EXTEND THE SUNSET
FOR THEM TO DO SO ASK YOUR
EITHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
GALLAGHER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS MOVE VERY. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESERTED THE. OUR
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF A-
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THAT I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE.
LIVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ. SALUDO NINE
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS IN
ARLINGTON SCREEN SAFETY THREE
OF US YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I'M
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM SPEAKER AB
NINE SEVENTY FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE TED CO AUTHORS TO
THE BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
MISS REAVIS SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
ADDITION OF CO AUTHORS THE
CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS OF.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
FIVE AB ONE ZERO ZERO TO THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME MIDDLETON
TO BUY SOME REMEMBER CHOI AND
OTHERS AN APPLE IN THE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. MISTER
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. AB ONE ZERO ZERO TWO
IS TO BACK ON CONCURRENT SO
WITH YOU TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS-
TO ADD OF COURSE THOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHERE YOU ARE
ABLE TO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER TRACING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS MOVED TO THIRD OF
THE- ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
THIRD OF. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THAT I SIXTIES
YOU KNOW ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY SIX EIGHTY TEN FIFTY
EIGHT THE COURT AGREED SO WE
WILL TEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND ACTIVATING THE WATER
SERVICE IT'S GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AND I
WANNA CONCURRENCE ON SENATE
AMENDMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS GARCIA SINGING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL.
CALL MEMBERS MOVED. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE THIRD OF THE- ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD OF THE. WHERE
TWELVE CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WE'VE ALREADY DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT AB ELEVEN
FORTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN FORTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROB RIVAS AND
ACCORDING TO FOOD SERVICE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THIS LEGISLATION MAKE A
NUMBER OF UPDATES TO
CALIFORNIA'S- ARE COLLEGE FOOD
LAWS THE MEMBERS COME FROM THE
CENTER MINOR- AND TECHNICAL
NATURE'S RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
INVESTING IN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE CALL MEMBERS
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS VOTED ERICA.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY TWO NEW
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY NINE EIGHTY TWELVE
OH THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OVAL THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AND
ACCORDING TO TAXATION IS BURKE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB TWELVE OH
THREE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE SAID AT A
SIX YEAR SUNSET I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST WE CAN CURRENT
SENTIMENT THANK YOU MISS BURKE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR. TO
OUR MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF A-
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY NO
THIRTEEN SENTIMENT ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE UP IN FILE ORDER
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SLIMMER MCCARTY AND I PLAYED A
STUDENT HOUSING IS MCCARTY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU BACK
ON SENATE CONCURRENCE TECHNICAL
BILL RELATE TO STUDENT HOUSING
OUT HERE I THINK YOU SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. HOME MEMBERS VOTED
AMERICA. ALL MEMBERS VERY
DESIRE TO GO. BURKE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALITA I SIXTY FOUR
NEWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN. FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE AB FOURTEEN FORTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARTY AND
ACTIVATING THE MENTAL HEALTH
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU BEEN SPEAKERS A
DISTRICT BILL TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THINKING.
THANK YOU MISTER CARTY SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THIRD OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED OUT OF IT. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THAT HIGH SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE WILL TAKE
UP FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT AB
TWO THIRTY NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY
NINE FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BE
APPROVED BY AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADES ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
DISTRIBUTED WHY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. AB TWO THIRTY NINE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. SAID IN
MINUTES AT A OP RESPECT ASK
YOUR NEIGHBOR. THANK YOU MISTER
ABE WHO DO I SING OVER DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR- CALL
MEMBERS MOVED. TO THE- HOME
VOTED THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS SAID TWO THIRDS VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW YOU THAT I SIXTY NEWS
SENATE ARE IN. WE WILL NOW.
BACK UP IN FILE ORDER TO. ITEM
TO SIX. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT THE
COURT. SOME PEOPLE IN BY SOME
BLOOM AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
ALL THE WAY MISTER LYNN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AS YOU KNOW THIS IS- AB
EIGHT EIGHTEEN REGARDING PROPER
LABELING FOR WET WIPES SITS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS
WERE TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING.
THIS IS BEEN A CONSENT ITEM AND
RECEIVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES THERE'S NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE WET WIPES THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE- IS
BOTH VERY VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TIGER I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WILL
NOW MOVE BACK TO FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEM SIXTY AB TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN THE CLERK. SOME PEOPLE
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM
ACALANES ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER TWELVE SIXTY SEVENS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL. NO OPPOSITION
RESPECT WESTERNIZED THANKS
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE IT. BURKE
WILL LOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU
THAT I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED
IN. MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
ONE AB TWELVE EIGHTY THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE TWELVE
EIGHTY BY SOME REMEMBER IRWIN
AND OTHERS NOT GOING INTO
HOSPICE. CARE WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AB TWELVE
EIGHTY IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THE AMENDMENTS ARE A TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR IBM THANK YOU MISS
IRWIN SINGING HEARING OVER THE
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS GO TO DESERT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY TWO AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN
BY SOME REMEMBER STONE
ACCORDING TO THE VERSION THIS
IS DOWN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
MAKE THIS BILL. MERELY AN
EXTENSION OF A SUNSET FOR
DEFERRED ENTRY OF JUDGMENT
PROGRAM IS VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM RUNNING IN SEVERAL OF
OUR COUNTIES FOR JUVENILES. I
REQUEST IT CONCURRENCE IN
SENTIMENT. THANK YOU MISTER
SENTENCING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD VOTE THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS ELEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE COULD HURT IN WE TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE AB THIRTEEN
FORTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA AND
OTHERS INCLUDING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH MISTER RANDALL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS. WHICH ADDED
SENATOR SKINNER AS A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER AMULET SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
THIRD OF THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED ESERVER CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TELEVOTE EYES FOR
YOU TO KNOW SIXTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING A FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOAN ACTIVITY TO
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. HELLO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MINISTRY CLEAR
COLLEAGUES AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN INCREASES TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOS SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. HOME
MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY TWO THERE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN LUNA FILE ITEM
SIXTY FIVE AB THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME OF
THE THIRTEEN NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO AN ACTOR IN
THE PRIVACY OF YOUR CHAO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER. AB
THIRTEENTH NINETY ONE IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAO'S SEEING HEARING NO.
FURTHER DELAY THE MATTER CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THERE HOME
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY A- WHERE
WILL LOSE THEIR OWN TALENT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING A FILE ITEM SIXTY SIXTY
B. FOURTEEN OH SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL REACH SOME WHO FORTINO
SEVEN BRYCE MEMBER BURKE AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE HEALTHCARE
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKE AB FORTINO
SEVEN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
IT WILL PROVIDE OUR STATE'S
NURSES WITH THE TOOLS TO
RECOGNIZE AND ADDRESS IT THIS
ADVICE IN OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND SUPPORTED BY THE-
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST THAT WE
CONCUR IN THE AMOUNT. THANK YOU
MISTER C. HEARING NO FURTHER TO
ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED. TO
THIRTY. ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU
DESERVE IT. OUR MEMBERS VOTER
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING THAT ICE FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE HAVE TO
SPECIFIED ITEM SIXTY SEVEN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT
AC ARE FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY RESOLUTION
FORTY SEVEN BY SOME ENORMOUS
OWN RELATIVE TO STAFF SERGEANT
ROBERT SCOTT JOHNSON MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY. DOWN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS OUR TECHNICAL ASK
YOUR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
DANCING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS GO TO LEARN ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD VOTE
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORD IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE ACR FIFTY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOLUTION FIFTY
TWO BISON LIVER PATTERSON AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE TOM
SEAVER MEMORIAL HIGHWAY
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS- ACR FIFTY TWO IS A
BACK FROM THE SENATE WITH A
SLIGHT AMENDMENT FOR THE
DISTANCE ALONG HIGHWAY FORTY
ONE. THAT WILL BE NAMED THE TOM
SEAVER MEMORIAL HIGHWAY HIGHWAY
ASK FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE. THANK
YOU MR PATTERSON THING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. CALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING ABOUT I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SEVENTY AC ARE SIXTY FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
COURAGE SOLUTION SIXTY FOUR BY
SUMMER FONG AND OTHER SPONSORS
OF THE HARLEY J. HOLMAN. STRONG
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I THANK YOU
MAN'S BIGGER EASIER SIXTY FOUR
SECOND CURRANTS CINNAMON
SPECIFY THE LOCATION OF THE
HIGHWAY WE NAMING AND ADD A CO
AUTHORS AS RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
KHAN SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER- WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS. HOME GO
TO THEIR. ALL MEMBERS OF HIS
ERA. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK UP IN FILE
ORDER TO AB. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
AB TO NINETY EIGHT. THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN AND ACCOLADES PROFESSIONS
OR VOCATIONS- WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AB TWO
NINE EIGHT MAKES MINOR CHANGES
TO THE RULES OF THE BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY SENATE AMENDMENTS
WERE MINOR AND TECHNICAL AND
THANK YOU FOR SPECTRALLY
ESPERANDO THANK YOU MISTER
WINCING IN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS ALL
MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE IT. HOME
MEMBERS VOTERS AREN'T VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK ON TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. WE WILL BE GOING
TO FILE ITEM TO- Q. S. B.
SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SIXTEEN BY SOON
SKINNER AND I PLAYED IN THE
PEACE OFFICERS. MISTER GRAYSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT SB SIXTEEN WHICH MODELS
MODESTLY EXPANDS PUBLIC ACCESS
TO POLICE RECORDS OF
MISCONDUCT. SB SIXTEEN IS IN
THEIR OLD REINTRODUCTION OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX FROM LAST YEAR
WHICH PASSED THIS FLOOR WITH
FIFTY THREE VOTES. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE OPEN ACCESS FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN FORTY YEARS TO
SET TO A LIMITED SET OF POLICE
RECORDS BUT LEFT OUT MANY
IMPORTANT CATEGORIES OF OFFICER
MISCONDUCT. SB SIXTEEN SEEKS TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY IN POLICE
OFFICER MISCONDUCT AND REBUILD
THE TRUST BETWEEN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS BY DOING
THE FOLLOWING. OPENING PUBLIC
ACCESS RECORDS WHERE AN
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION LED TO A
SUSTAIN FINDING THAT THE
OFFICER ENGAGED IN ON
REASONABLE OR EXCESSIVE FORCE
RACIST HOMOPHOBIC ANTI SEMITIC
OR OTHER BIAS ACTIONS AND
UNLAWFUL ARREST WERE SEARCHES
REQUIRING RECORDS TO BE
ESTABLISHED IF AN OFFICER
RESIGNS. PRIOR TO AN
INVESTIGATION MANDATING HIRING
AGENCIES REVIEW DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS AND USE OF FORCE PRIOR
TO HIRING OFFICERS MANDATING
THAT AGENCIES KEEPS THE STATE
RECORDS OF MISCONDUCT FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS AND I'M SUSTAIN
RECORDS FOR FIVE YEARS. THE
AUTHOR HAS WORKED DILIGENTLY
WITH OPPONENTS AND HAS EARNED
THE SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND
NEUTRALITY OF ALL OTHER MAJOR
STATEWIDE POLICE OFFICER UNIONS
MOST RECENTLY THE LA POLICE
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE SAID THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO NEUTRAL ALONG
WITH SAN DIEGO. DEPUTY
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION THIS IS A MODEST
EXPANSION OF PUBLIC RECORDS LAW
RELATED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
MISCONDUCT. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAYSON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY TO THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL COOL LOSE THEIR ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY
FOUR NEWS TEN. ASIS.
MEMBERS WE
ARE NOW MOVING TO THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR. TO LOOK. AT
FILE ITEMS TO EIGHTY THREE TO
EIGHTY NINE AND FILE ITEM TO
NINETY ONE THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR SO BEFORE WE TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE WILL
TAKE UP THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR PURPOSES
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. HOUSE WAS
VERSION SIXTY THREE BY SIMPLY
REVERSING OUR TO RELATIVE TO
SERVICE TALK APPRECIATION MONTH
HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO THE VALLEY. HOUSE
RESOLUTION SUCCEED BY SIMPLY
MEMORY IS RELATIVE TO
CHILDREN'S ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
MONTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIXTY NINE BY SOME
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA RELATIVE
TO INTERNATIONAL DAY OF PEACE.
ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
OF SEVEN MONTHS AND RURAL
AMERICANS ALL SORTS OF THE
BREAST CANCER AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH. HOUSE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY VICE IN THE
RIVER REYES MOTIVE TO THE
TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
ONE. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY ONE BY CENTER
PAN AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
SACRAMENTO MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT INCIDENT CURRENT
pHUESO. AND OTHERS RULES OF A
PUBLIC POWER WEEK. THANK YOU
THE CLERK WILL. THE ROLE ALLOW
ANY MEMBER CHAD ON OF THE CO OP.
THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS TO THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TWO THIRDS VOTE
THIS IS FOR COOPER'S.
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT%
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
EITHER TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THOUGH
THERE ARE SIXTY FOUR CO AUTHORS
TO THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE WILL NOW
NEW MOVE TO A VOTE ON THE
CONTENT CALENDAR FILE ITEMS TO
EIGHTY THREE TO TWO NINETY TWO.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ THE
SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR
POSTPOSITION SIXTY THREE BY
SOME MEMBERS THEY ARE TO
RELATIVE TO SERVICE TALK
APPRECIATION MONTH. WELL OVER
THERE ON THE CAN. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SIXTY SEVEN I
SEVEN ZERO ZERO HOUSE WAS
LOSING SIXTY. POUNDS WAS LOSING
SIXTY NINE SEVENTY YOU KNOW
THERE ARE SOME THE CURRENT
RESOLUTION WHILE. SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN EIGHT ZERO ZERO COUNCIL
SOLUTION SEVENTY. CURRENTLY
FIFTY ONE. ZERO SENATE BILL
TWENTY TWO. SOLUTION FORTY NINE
ZERO ZERO INSTAGRAMMER FIFTY
FOUR I. SEVEN ZERO ZERO. IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
THE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY I PLEASE
ASK YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR. MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION. MISTER GIBSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY
MEMORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JOHNNY
BEATRICE WILLIAMS OF CARSON
CALIFORNIA. MISS WILLIAMS ALSO
KNOWN AS MAMA JOHNNY PASSED
AWAY AT THE AT THE HUMBLE AGE
OF NINETY ONE YEARS OF AGE
JOHNNY BE WHITE WAS BORN IN
BENTON LOUISIANA ON NOVEMBER
ELEVENTH NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
TO FRANK WHITE SENIOR LUCY A
WHITE. SHE WAS THE SECOND
YOUNGEST OF EIGHT CHILDREN BORN
TO THIS UNION IN NINETEEN FORTY
SIX JOHNNY. HER MOTHER LUCILA
AN OLDER BROTHER FRANK MOVED TO
SAN PEDRO CALIFORNIA TO REUNITE
WITH THEIR SET WITH HER
SIBLINGS JOHNNY ATTENDED ST
PETER HIGH SCHOOL AND GRADUATED
IN NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT AND
WENT ON TO ATTEND METROPOLITAN
SCHOOL. TWENTY METROPOLITAN
SCHOOL OF BUSINESS IN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA DURING THIS TIME
SHE MET AND MARRIED ALTON
TREMBLE SENIOR AND HAD FOUR
LOVELY BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN AFTER
HER CAREER AS A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST. SHE REUNITED. WITH A
WONDERFUL MAN BY NAME OF JAMES
LEE WILLIAMS OF TEXAS IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE CANTON
CHURCH OF CHURCH OF GOD IN
CHRIST IN WILMINGTON CALIFORNIA
BECAME HER HOME CHURCH JOHNNY
SPIRITUAL LIFE- DEEPENED AT THE
AGE OF TWENTY YEARS OF AGE WHEN
SHE SOLIDIFIED HER RELATIONSHIP
WITH HER CRISIS AND ACCEPTED
HIM AS HER LORD AND SAVIOR
JOHNNY EXPRESSED. SHE EXPRESSED
AND SAID THAT THIS WAS THE BEST
THING THAT SHE EVER- THIS YOU
EVER DID AND THAT IS TO ACCEPT
CHRIST AS OUR LORD AND SAVIOR.
JOHNNY BECAME INVOLVED IN THE
CHURCH BY SERVING IN THE ADULT
SUNDAY SCHOOL OF MINISTRY AND
TAUGHT BIBLE STUDY TO YOUNG
WOMEN'S AT THE WEST ANGELES
CHURCH OF GOD IN CHRIST IN LOS
ANGELES. SHE MODELED A. B. A
BIBLICAL WALK WITH CHRIST
PROVIDING HER HER. HER WALK AS
AN EXAMPLE FOR OTHER YOUNG
WOMEN TO FOLLOW SHE BECAME
KNOWN AS MAMA JOHNNY OR MOTHER
JOHNNY AFTER JOINING THE GLORY
CHRISTIAN. FELLOWSHIP
INTERNATIONAL CHURCH UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF HER SON PASTOR
ALTON TREMBLE. AND FIRST LADY
JUDITH D. TREMBLE JOHNNY IS A
SPIRITUAL WARRIOR AND NEVER
MISS AN OPPORTUNITY TO PRAY
WITH AND FOR MANY PEOPLE WHOSE
REQUESTED. AND SHE WENT BEFORE
GOD TO PETITION GOD ON THEIR
BEHALF SHE LEAVES TO CHERISH
BEHIND A LEGACY OF FAMILIES WHO
CHERISHED AND LOVED AND ADORED
HER. SHE IS REMEMBERED FOR HER
KINDNESS HER WARM HUGS AND HER
SERVICE TO OTHERS THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
US TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF
THIS GREAT WOMAN THAT I CALL%
GRANNY SHE WILL BE MISSED BY US
ALL I KNOW IS YOU PRAY FOR ME
AND SHE PULLED ME THROUGH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
GIPSON. MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THE LOTTO CATHERINE HADLEY
ROBINSON WAS A PILLAR OF MY
COMMUNITY AND HER FAMILY WHICH
LEFT AN INDELIBLE MARK ON THE
WORLD. SHE WAS BORN IN
THOMASVILLE GEORGIA AND WAS THE
EIGHTH OF FIFTEEN CHILDREN. HE
WAS POPULAR AND WELL LOVED EVEN
IN HER EARLY YEARS BECOMING
HOMECOMING QUEEN AT HER HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FIFTY ONE.
SHE SETTLED IN PASADENA WHERE
SHE MARRIED MACK ROBINSON IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE. HE WENT ON
TO BECOME THE NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX SILVER MEDALISTS IN THE TWO
HUNDRED METERS AT THE BERLIN
OLYMPIC GAMES IN GERMANY. WHERE
HE BROKE A WORLD RECORD BUT
FINISHED BEHIND JESSE OWENS.
SHE WAS ALSO THE SISTER IN LAW
OF JACKIE ROBINSON WHO BROKE
THE COLOR BARRIER IN BASEBALL.
THIS FAMILY MARKS THIS FAMILIES
MARK ON BLACK HISTORY AND
AMERICAN HISTORY IS INDELIBLE
AND ELENA'S ROLE IN THAT IS
UNQUESTIONABLE. SHE ENJOYED
VOLUNTEERING AT THEIR WORK ARCO
JESSE OWENS GAMES OF THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DILLON ALSO ATTENDED
MANY EVENTS WHICH PROMOTED THE
DODGERS MLB. AND TEAM USA
OLYMPICS DELANO'S CAREER WAS IN
NURSING WHERE SHE EXPERIENCED.
AND SHE ATTAINED ASSISTED HER
IN TAKING CARE OF HER BELOVED
HUSBAND MACK ROBINSON UNTIL HIS
DEATH ON MARCH TWELFTH TWO
THOUSAND. AS ONE OF THE WOMEN
OF ACHIEVEMENT AND PASADENA.
SHE PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST
EIGHTEENTH LEAVING MANY
GRANDCHILDREN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN SIBLINGS FAMILY
FRIENDS AND A LEGACY WHICH IS
SECOND TO NONE. I LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR JOINING IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN MR COOLEY
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. COLLEAGUES I AM VERY
HONORED TO RISE TODAY FOR
SOMEONE WHO I KNEW EARLY IN MY
CAREER- THE HONORABLE MICHAEL
GAGE. MICHAEL WAS A MEMBER OF
THE STATE ASSEMBLY AND- HE
SERVED BACK IN THE DAYS OF THE
SPEAKERSHIP OF LEO MCCARTHY.
AND SO HE IS IN THAT CLASS OF
MEMBERS WHO BECAUSE HE WAS HERE
TWO YEARS. NEVER SERVE IN THIS
CHAMBER. UNLESS PERHAPS YOU
SWORN IN HERE EARLY ON. BUT
MICHAEL GAGE WAS. AN INTREPID
GUY IN A LIFETIME EXPLORE. AND
HE PASSED AWAY JUST MONDAY OF
LAST WEEK. AUGUST TWENTY THIRD
AFTER SUCCUMBING TO CANCER AT
AGE SEVENTY SIX. MY GAUGE WAS
BORN ON MAY ONE NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE TO MARY AND GEORGE GAGE IN
GLENDALE CALIFORNIA. UPON
GRADUATION FROM HIGH SCHOOL HE
ENROLLED IN THE ARMY. BECAME A
PARATROOPER ARMY AIRBORNE. SO I
ASSURE YOU HE WAS INTREPID WAYS
YOU AND I MIGHT FEAR. DURING
THIS TIME WHO DISCOVER A LOVE
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND FOR
POLITICS FROM HIS MILITARY
SERVICE. AFTER THE ARMY STILL
HAS YOU IN HIS EARLY TWENTIES
HE WENT TO WORK AS A CHOKER
SETTER IN ALASKA. DURING THE
SUMMER OF NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
THAT'S MEAN HE WAS A PART OF A
LOGGING TEAM IS TREES WERE
FELLED AND THEY WERE LAMB
REDUCING THEM TO TRUNKS
SOMEBODY HAD TO SET THE CABLES
TO HAUL IT OFF SITE. TO
CONTINUE ON HIS JOURNEY VERY
HARD TREACHEROUS ENERGETIC JOB
AND THAT'S WHAT HE DID IN THE
SUMMER OF SIXTY SEVEN THE
SUMMER OF LOVE- AND HE- FORMED
OPINIONS IN THAT AIR ABOUT HOW
HE VIEWED THE TREATMENT OF OUR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT. AND THEY
WOULD INFLUENCE HIS WHOLE
CAREER. HE EVENTUALLY DURING
THIS TIME DURING THE SEVENTIES
IS WHEN HE SERVED TWO TERMS IN
THE STATE ASSEMBLY. HE WAS A
PART OF THAT ERA THAT PASSED
THE ORIGINAL LRB LAW DURING
JERRY BROWN'S FIRST TERM.
WORKING A VERY VERY MONUMENTAL
ACCOMPLISHMENT IN YOUNG
GOVERNOR BROWN'S FIRST TERM IN
OFFICE. ARM. HERE'S REMEMBER
FOR NEVER DISCUSSING HIS TIME
AS A LAWMAKER. WITHOUT
EMPHASIZING HIS STAFF. WHOM WE
ALWAYS SAID WORKED WITH HIM NOT
FOR HIM. TO TELL YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF HIS MIND SET. HE
EVENTUALLY IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY NINE ALSO SERVED
AS THE LOS ANGELES DEPUTY MAYOR.
AND CHAIR OF THE POWERFUL LA
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER.
THE COMMISSION AND- M. W. D. AS
SOMETHING CALIFORNIA THAT WAS
DURING THE TENURE OF TOM
BRADLEY AS MAYOR. A VERY
IMPORTANT TIME IN HIS LIFE TO
SERVER TOM BRADLEY AND THAT'S
ROLE. OF THIS PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREER HE RECENTLY WROTE
BECAUSE HE PUT A FACEBOOK
POSTING. ABOUT SIX WEEKS BEFORE
HE PASSED AWAY RIGHT BEFORE
WENT INTO HOSPICE CARE. HE
WROTE I LOVE MY TIME AS A STATE
LEGISLATOR AND I BELIEVE I DID
A GOOD JOB. HAVE AN OUTSTANDING
STAFF TO HELP ME I GOT SOME
DECENT WORK DONE SAID MIKE GAGE.
I WAS A SOLID SUPPORTER JERRY
BROWN AS GOVERNOR AND
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE. STILL
HAVE CLOSE FRIENDS WITH THAT
EARLIER. HE CAMERA
INTERESTINGLY I MAY HAVE
ENJOYED MY TIME WORKING ON
PUBLIC POLICY AS A STAFF GUY.
MORE THAN MY TIME AS A
LEGISLATOR. I LOVE THE MULTIPLE
YEARS WORKING AS STAFF TO THE
LEGISLATURE JOHN DUNLOP WHO
REGARD AS HIS CHOSEN MENTOR.
LIAM MCCARTHY. AND THEN WITH
TOM BRADLEY. HE SAID WORKING AS
TOM BRADLEY AS DEPUTY MAYOR AND
CHIEF OF STAFF WAS AN HONOR AND
A PRIVILEGE. AFTER DECLINE THE
THIRD TERM THE STATE ASSEMBLY
MIKE DECIDED TO TAKE HIS LOVE
FOR ADVENTURE IN THE OUTDOORS
TO RIVER RAFTING. BECAME A
RAFTING GUIDE WITH THE FIRM
OWNERS SO BACK EXPEDITIONS. AND
OF THAT PART OF HIS LIFE MIKE
GAGE STATED IN THIS RECENT
FACEBOOK POST IN JULY OF THIS
YEAR. AS A WHITE WATER RAFTING
GUIDE AND BOATMEN IN ALASKA THE
GRAND CANYON AND INDIA PAKISTAN
CHILE TURKEY ZAMBIA AND
ZIMBABWE. I WAS ABLE SEE
SEVERAL SMALL PARTS OF THE
WORLD UNIQUELY INTIMATELY AS
INDEED I'M SURE HE DID FOR THE
RIVER. MIKE'S FEARLESS SPIRIT
AND MULTI FACETED CHARACTER
WOULD BRIEFLY TO WORKERS
REPORTER FOR NBC FOUR IN LOS
ANGELES. RIGHT BEFORE BECOMING
PRESIDENT AND CEO SEE YOUR WAS-
NONPROFIT CAL START. WE DEVELOP
CLEAN ENERGY SOLUTIONS
INCLUDING ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
MICROLAND CONVENTIONAL PATH ONE
OF MANY MIGHT FEAR PURSUING
TODAY. HIS UNIQUE DISINTERMENT
RARE OUTLOOK ON LIFE WILL STAND
MAKE HIM STAND OUT TODAY
TOMORROW AND FOREVER. AS
REMEMBER THIS MEMBER OF OUR
MOST AUGUST BODY. HE WROTE AND
PUBLISHED AS A SAID HIS OWN
FACEBOOK A BRIDGE WERE SIX
WEEKS BEFORE HIS UNTIMELY DEATH.
HE WAS THE COMPETITION YET VERY
UNASSUMING AND SELF EFFACING
MAN. KERN OF THOSE QUALITIES TO
BE AN MIKE IN TITLE HIS JULY
EIGHTH ONLINE OBITUARY AS-
WEIRD KID ENDS UP WITH A GREAT
LIFE. AND WHAT A WAY TO REGARD
ONE'S LIFE AS ONE FACES IT'S IN.
I'M MIKE GAGE FORMER MEMBER OF
OUR BODY IS SURVIVED BY HIS
BELOVED WIFE LACI HIS SON DAMON
AND A SIX GRANDCHILDREN AUGUST
MAKAYLA LANGLAIS SO FOR YOUR
PLAYER AND THEN. ALL OF WHOM
ADDED TO THE TREASURED. A GREAT
LIFE REMEMBER HIM FOR TODAY AND
I THANK YOU THAT WE DURING HIS
BERMAN. THANK YOU MR COOLEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADDITIONAL GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES. I
LIKEWISE RISE TODAY IN THE
MEMORY OF SOMEONE WHO MIGHT
HAVE KNOWN OVER MY CAREER-
TIMOTHY LAME COIL. HE SERVED AS
A PUBLIC SERVANT. LOVER HUSBAND
AND FATHER AND A FRIEND-
TIMOTHY COYLE PASSED WHEN JULY
EIGHTH OF THIS YEAR AT THE AGE
OF SIXTY EIGHT. TIM WAS BORN ON
AUGUST TWENTY NINE NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA. TO CHARLIE AND
CAROL CORAL. HE WOULD LATER
GRADUATE FROM CENTER STATE
UNIVERSITY HAVING PURSUED A BA
IN JOURNALISM IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. HIS PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREER BEGAN WHEN HE ACCEPTED A
POSITION WITH THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT. HIS EXCETIONAL
DECORUM AND WORK ETHIC WOULD BE
TO HOLD SEVERAL EXECUTIVE
POSITIONS UNDER TWO PRESIDENTS
RONALD REAGAN AND GEORGE BUSH.
IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE HE MOVED
TO SEVERAL SIR GOVERNOR PETE
WILSON AS A DIRECTOR OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT UNTIL
NINETEEN NINETY SIX. TIM COYLE
THEN WENT TO WORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. WHERE HE WOULD
WORK FOR FIFTEEN YEARS UNTIL
FINALLY RETIRING IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AS AN ADVOCATE. TIMOTHY
CONTINUED AFTER HIS LOVE FOR
POLICY IN WRITING BY WRITING
PROLIFICALLY ON PUBLIC POLICY
SHOULD FOR VARIOUS MEDIA
OUTLETS. TIMOTHY LANE CALLER
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE THROUGH
HIS SONS CHRIS AND KEVIN COYLE
AND HIS SIBLINGS MATT JAN PAM
AND JENNY. AND I THINK THE
PROVISION OF A JOURNEYMAN
TIMOTHY LANE CLOSE MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR COOLEY
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAME
SAID SB PRINT IN THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUEST RETURNING MEMORY WE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
THURSDAY SEPTEMBER SECOND FLOOR
SESSION AT TEN AM FRIDAY
SEPTEMBER THIRD FLOOR SESSION
AT NINE AM ALL OTHER ITEMS ARE
MEETING WILL BE PASSED RETAINED
ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISS RASMUSSEN MISTER GIBSON
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
SEPTEMBER. SECOND AT TEN AM.
BECAUSE WHAT DID. EUROPE. YEP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
VOTE CHANGE ON FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR I
TO NOT VOTING. NO CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN A
SINGLE THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR I DO
NOT VOTING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIAM VOTE CHANGE MOTION AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE NO T<c.cyan>.</c>
NO TIME. CHANGE IS THE MEMBER
BELIEVE MOTION TO RE REFER NO
TÁI. WELL. AB. TWENTY SIX. AB
TWENTY SIX. YEAH I REMEMBER.
TWELVE I DIDN'T. YEAH YES
DONALD. CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
ADHANOM. YEAH STEVEN CHOI WILL
CHANGE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY SIX ALL RIGHT TO KNOW.
EVEN WHEN I. CERVANTES FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE AB THIRTEEN
FORTY FOUR I TO NOT VOTING.
WILL CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN
FORTY FOUR I DO NOT BELIEVE.
OKAY I WANT A CAREER FILE ITEM
NINETY NINE SB FIVE FIVE SIX I
TEND NOT VOTING. WELL CHANGES
MEMBER CARILLO SENATE BILL FIVE
OH SIX I DO NOT VOTING.
CORRECTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO SENATE BILL FIVE NINE
SIX ARGONAUTE LOADING.
YEAH. WE
ARE.
YOUR.
HAVE. YEAH. YEAH. OR.
YEAH.
THE MAJORITY OF THE.
OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
VOTE CHANGE SB FIVE FIVE SIX
FROM I TO NOT VOTING. BURKE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY
SIX I DO NOT VOTING.
GALLAGHER
VOTE CHANGE A. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR I TO ANOTHER IN THE-
BOTH CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER SYMBOL FOURTEEN FORTY
FOUR I TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ VOTE
CHANGE A. B. FORM FOR TWENTY
EIGHT FROM ITEM NUMBER. WE'LL
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ SOME LEGAL FOR TWENTY
EIGHT- TO NOT BUILDING.
I.
NO-
OKAY.